[Musique]
Eric Zemour, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Je m'appelle Éric Zemour.
Euh j'ai 63 ans. Je suis né
à Montreuil en Saint Sandy en le 31 août
d'une famille
qui venait donc qui venait d'Algérie
qui était donc de la grande famille pied
noire et j'ai grandi
j'ai grandi dans la banlieue parisienne
j'ai grandi à Drancy et puis ensuite on
est venu à Paris dans le 18e
arrondissement dans les années 70
et puis ensuite j'ai fait sciences pot.
J'étais diplômé de sciences pot en 79
et j'ai passé l'ENA en 80 81. J'ai été
admissible, vous savez c'est il y avait
a deux parties, l'écrit et l'oral et
donc j'ai eu l'écrit donc j'étais
admissible et je n'ai pas eu l'oral. Et
puis ensuite euh j'ai un peu travaillé
dans la publicité mais ça m'a pas plu du
tout et j'étais euh journaliste au
quotidien de Paris euh de Philippe
Tesson et puis ensuite je suis je suis
passé par des 1 an et demi à Infomatin
journal qui a disparu qui était dirigé
par André Rousselet vous savez le le et
puis je suis allé au Figaro à 97
j'étais journaliste au Figaro. J'ai
écrit des livres, d'abord des livres de
journalistes politiques,
un portrait de baladure, un portrait de
chirak, puis des romans, puis des essais
sur la justice, sur la droite, sur
euh euh
des des romans, euh des des livres
d'histoire, je dirais, d'histoire de
France, mais à ma façon, mélancolie
française, destin français et puis j'ai
écrit le destin français. le le suicide
français qui était une analyse de de de
ce que je considérais comme une
décadence depuis 40 ans et qui a eu un
un succès retentissant et voilà, j'ai
écrit aussi le mon dernier livre La
France n'a pas dit son dernier mot est
sorti en septembre. Voilà, je je suis
marié, j'ai trois enfants.
Toutes vos dents ?
Toutes peut-être pas. Non, il doit
manquer une là.
Et puis euh voilà. Euh j'ai j'ai fait
aussi des émissions de télévision, mais
ça les gens connaissent davantage. Euh
donc j'étais chez On n'est pas couché
pendant 5 ans et puis au Zemorenolo.
Euh et puis la dernière passe à l'info
les 2 ans sur C News avec mes amis
Christine Kelly, Marc Menant et et
voilà.
Donc vous nous aviez vous nous avez dit
qu'on avait pas beaucoup de temps avec
vous. Euh, j'ai dit que non. J'ai dit
que 1h30, on a vous m'avez dit 1h30
minimum. J'ai dit bah 1h30 c'est bien.
Euh voilà, on peut on peut on peut
toujours mais voilà, ça me paraît
beaucoup. C'est déjà beaucoup de temps,
il me semble. Mais bon,
une heure
et vous voulez rester avec moi, vous
m'aimez déjà beaucoup.
Euh je sais pas si on peut dire queon
vous aime, mais chez nous, on commence à
à se dérouiller que à partir d'une
heure.
Ah ou là ! Et moi je je vais me
dérouiller, je vais me dérouiller plus
vite. Alors allez-y, on va parler
politique étrangère, finance,
terrorisme, hacking et pourquoi on en
est arrivé là. H
h
Je vous laisse l'honneur de choisir le
terrain.
Allez-y dans l'ordre. Politique
étrangère comme vous voulez. Comme vous
voulez.
C'est vous qui choisissez. Moi c'est
vous qui interviez. OK. Qu'est-ce qui se
passe ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Ouais. Qu'est-ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ?
Ouais.
Euh
qu'est-ce qui se passe selon Éric Zemour
? Nous avons une situation
pour moi qui va occuper tout le 21e
siècle mais je je n'ai pas l'impression
de dire quelque chose de très original
qui est l'affrontement
entre les États-Unis et la Chine qui va
dominer
toute la planète pendant tout le siècle
qui a déjà commencé mais je vous dis
vraiment j'ai pas l'impression de
découvrir la Lune. Simplement pour
remettre dans le contexte, je pense que
c'est une
nouvelle
ressuscé d'un affrontement classique. Je
dirais un double affrontement classique.
D'abord un affrontement classique. Vous
savez que ce professeur américain a
appelé le piège de Tucidide,
c'est-à-dire quand il y a une puissance
déclinante et qu'une puissance montante,
il est rare qu'on échappe à au conflit
armé. Euh la puissance descendante étant
évidemment les États-Unis, la puissance
montante étant évidemment euh la Chine.
Nous avons connu ça dans le passé. On
peut dire par exemple d'ailleurs le le
professeur, je crois que c'est Alison
son nom euh donne de multiples exemples.
Moi, j'en avais en tête de simple,
c'est-à-dire euh la France de Napoléon
qui contre l'Angleterre de l'époque et
l'Allemagne de la fin du 19e siècle
contre l'Angleterre. puissance des
désormais descendante après avoir été la
puissance montante contre Napoléon. Euh
et il y a d'autres exemples évidemment
et je dirais c'est doublé d'un d'un
d'une autre un d'autre classique de
l'histoire géostratégique
qui est d'ailleurs la même chose que les
exemples que je vous ai cés,
c'est-à-dire un affrontement entre la
mer et la terre, entre la puissance
maritime, en l'occurrence les États-Unis
comme il l'Angleterre précédemment et la
puissance terrestre comme la Chine,
comme il y l'Allemagne donc en 14 et la
France de Napoléon et de Louis XIV euh
auparavant. Et cet affrontement assez
classique, on peut relire tous les
classiques de la géopolitique.
Quelle est la clé de voûte de cet
affrontement là ? Est-ce que vous pouvez
le
la mer et la terre ? La mer et la terre,
je pense c'est l'affrontement entre la
mer et la terre. La clé de voûte, c'est
ça et les et on pourrait même un un
troisème affrontement que là j'emprunte
davantage à d'autres auteurs comme E
Huttington et René Crouset. qui est
l'affrontement entre l'Orient et
l'Occident. C'est-à-dire que je pense
qu'il y a un un un troisème affrontement
qui est cet affrontement entre l'Orient
et l'Occident. Depuis René Grous dit
depuis euh
le le la Grèce antique qui affrontait la
Perse puis l'Empire romain, voyez,
contre contre l'Orient et on peut comme
ça remonter le temps et et Grouset
explique très bien que cet affrontement
entre l'Orient et l'Ocusion n'a jamais
cessé et que à partir du 7e siècle, du
8e siècle de de l'éruption de l'islam
dans le monde, l'Orient a trouvé son
porte drapeau qui est l'islam et il y a
eu des vagues incessantes de flux et de
reflus de conquête et et de reconquête
et de et et de libération. Oui,
si vous m'autorisez à vous couper,
bah laissez-moi finir au moins mon
analyse.
Allez-y.
Je vous avez du temps, alors
profitons-en. Euh et donc entre l'islam
et la chrétienté sur 1000 ans d'histoire
et aujourd'hui, c'est ce qui donne une
connotation encore une fois de guerre,
de civilisation que évidemment
j'emprunte à Huttington. Nous avons un
affrontement entre l'Orient et
l'Occident qui est double. C'est-à-dire
que nous avons cet affrontement entre
l'Amérique et la Chine,
ce que j'ai décrit tout à l'heure, et
l'affrontement entre l'Islam et les
terres chrétiennes européennes. Cet
affrontement est donc double, cet
affrontement de civilisation et euh il
ne se évidemment il ne vous voyez bien
qu'il n'est pas du même registre. D'un
côté, il y a une volonté de la Chine de
de jouer avec les armes authentiques de
l'hégémonie mondiale, armes économiques,
armes militaires, armes, voyez, vraiment
géostratégique. Et puis de l'autre côté,
nous avons une une guerre de
civilisation dans la guerre de
civilisation, c'est-à-dire avec l'Islam
qui après s'être libéré de la domination
occidentale qui avait commencé avec la
conquête de l'Égypte par Bonaparte en
1798, désormais passe à l'offensive par
la démographie évidemment d'abord et
avant tout la démographie donc la
conquête de territoire par une
population islamique et l'argent,
l'influence d'autres pays et cetera. Et
je pense que le 21e siècle, c'est ça va
être cet affrontement de civilisation et
entre l'Orient et l'Occident tel que je
l'ai décrit euh depuis quelques minutes.
Qu'est-ce marotte ici ? C'est une de nos
marottes, c'est la relation de cause à
effet entre pic énergétique et
terrorisme. H
est-ce que vous voyez une relation de
cause à effet entre pic énergétique et
terrorisme ? Qu'est-ce que le pic
énergétique ? Hm. Le pic énergétique,
c'est le fait qu'il y ait plus de
pétrole, c'est ça ?
Non, je ne je ne crois pas qu'il y a un
rapport. Il y aura toujours du pétrole
d'ailleurs hein.
Mais absolument. C'est pour ça que je
vous dis ça d'abord et je
pour je vais je vais vous avez l'air pas
très familier avec le sujet donc je vais
je vais délayuer délayer mes mots.
Exact.
Euh la capacité à avoir de la calorie
facile,
que ce soit de la calorie alimentaire ou
de la calorie que vous utilisez dans
votre transport,
quand le gâteau se rarfie, h
les chevaux se battent.
Quand il n'y a plus de foin dans les
rateliers, les chevaux se battent. Quel
quels est vos quelles sont vos
connaissances sur le pic tout,
c'est-à-dire pic matériaux, pic
énergétique, pic de composants ?
Écoutez, je n'ai pas une science
apparemment aussi approfondie que la
vôtre. Je dis simplement que j'entends
ça depuis 40 ans. Je suis plus vieux que
vous et je j'entends ça depuis 40 ans,
qu'il y aura un pic du pétrole, un pic
de ceci, un pic de cela et on découvre
toujours de nouvelles ressources. Euh
par ailleurs euh
on découvre les les ressources où et par
qui ?
Bah par qui ? Par les occidentaux qui
sont toujours ceux qui découvrent depuis
depuis 100 ans, depuis euh la la
découverte du pétrole. Euh et mais je ne
vois, pardonnez-moi, je ne vois pas du
tout le rapport entre l'un et l'autre.
D'abord, moi j'appelle pas ça de
terrorisme, j'appelle ça du djihadisme.
Le terrorisme c'est une chose, c'est du
terrorisme catou, il y a du terrorisme
mais justement justement je je le
terrorisme pour moi c'est une offensive,
vous savez c'est une forme de guerre
asymétrique. Vous savez ce que c'est la
guerre asymétrique ? Évidemment ce n'est
pas la guerre entre deux états comme les
guerres de Napoléon ou comme la guerre
14. C'est une une guerre d'un groupe
contre un État ou contre une nation pour
le faire plier par des moyens euh qui
qui qui
euh qui harcèle qui obsèd tellement sa
population qu'il saite. On peut parler
par exemple de terrorisme d'extrême
gauche communiste dans les années 70, je
me souviens très très bien de ça, de des
brigades rouges en Italie, de la bande
àabadaire en Allemagne ou même du
terrorisme récemment récemment dans les
pays nordiques
ou récemment dans les pays nordiques, je
vois pas.
Utoya, ça vous parle ?
Bravic, vous voulez dire
? C'est pas du terrorisme, c'est un
massacre.
C'est c'est pas pour faire plier le
gouvernement
de Norvégien ou non, c'est pour c'est un
massacre. C'est pas du terrorisme pour
moi, c'est un massacre horrible. Euh
voilà. Euh mais c'est je je vois pas
comme un terrorisme. Mais bon, en tout
cas, tel dans la définition que je le
donne. Euh c'est un massacre terrifiant
et et fou. Mais voilà, je je il y a pas
de suite d'ailleurs, il y a pas eu j'ai
pas vu de de suite. Il y a pas de de il
y a pas de revendication. Il y a pas de
bon euh le terrorisme d'extrême gauche,
il y avait des revendications, il y
avait une volonté de montrer que en
vérité le vrai visage de la démocratie,
le vrai visage de la démocratie que ce
qui selon eux était une dictature. Et
ces gens-là d'extrême, je me souviens
très bien de leur discours, j'étais
adolescent donc je m'en souviens très
très bien, voulit montrer que en fait ce
qu'on appelait la démocratie
parlementaire n'était qu'en fait une
forme
sophistiquée de fascisme. et il voulait
radicaliser l'État pour que il prive de
liberté à ça c'est du terrorisme.
On peut aussi, il y a le terrorisme
pour s'émanciper
le le terrorisme du FLN contre la France
pendant la guerre d'Algérie qui mettait
des bombes.
Terrorisme ou résistance.
Moi, j'appelle ça terrorisme, mais vous
avez raison. Euh vous avez tout à fait
raison. Même les résistants France Non,
non mais vous avez raison, vous avez
raison. Le le résistant, c'est quand on
s'émancipe et le terroriste, c'est quand
on subit euh cette action. Vous avez
raison. pour les Allemands, les
résistants Jean Moulin étaient des
terroristes. Donc je ne je ne joue pas
sur les mots. Pour moi, c'est du
terrorisme parce que je suis français et
que donc je suis toujours pour la
France. Mais vous avez raison, pour eux
c'est de la résistance. Donc vous voyez,
je je ne je ne joue pas sur les mots
avec vous. Euh maintenant pareil pour
les Palestiniens avec les Israéliens,
pour les Israéliens, c'est les
terroristes, pour les Palestiniens,
c'est des résistants. Après, chacun
choisi ses mots. Vous avez tout à fait
raison. Selon son camp.
La France se positionne làdessus.
Alors, j'ai pas fini euh puisque je
réponds à votre question sur le P. Je je
ne je ne pense pas que ce qu'on a vécu
depuis euh 2012, depuis Mohamed Mera,
depuis 2015, Charlie, le Bataclan, euh
le le l'égorgement de Samuel Patti,
l'égorgement des de prêtres dans leur
euh dans leur église ou de la policière
dans son commissariat, je ne pense pas
que ce soit du terrorisme. Je pense que
c'est du djihadisme. C'est-à-dire que le
djihad, c'est la conquête d'un
territoire par l'islam par des moyens
violents qui est prescrit par le Coran.
Tout est écrit dans le Coran en
l'occurrence et qui ordonne aux
musulmans de conquérir des territoires
pour islamiser les populations et pour
islamiser le monde. C'est l'objectif de
l'islam et du Coran. Euh et euh dans ce
cas-là euh si vous voulez euh euh
nous avons donc des des des gens qui qui
qui agressent des populations infidèles
pour les transformer en sujet d'Allah.
L'Islam fonctionne selon de une
catégorie binaire. Il y a euh ce qu'ils
appellent le darelislam et le darel hab,
c'est-à-dire le monde de l'islam et le
monde de la guerre. Et et Darel Salam,
ben
oui, darislam, c'est la même chose. Dar
Salam, c'est le monde de la paix mais
c'est le monde de l'Islam parce que on a
la paix que quand on est converti et
soumis à l'Islam et soumis à Dieu. C'est
la même chose. Il y a la même c'est
islam veut dire soumission et elle a la
même racine que salam parce queon a la
paix que dans la soumission. L'islam est
une moi j'estime que c'est une religion
totalitaire, c'est-à-dire qui prend en
compte tous les les toutes les
composantes de l'existence humaine qui
ne connaît pas l'individu et qu'il
considère que on est émancipé par la
soumission à Dieu.
Vous croyez en Dieu ? Euh ça dépend des
jours ça dépend des jours c'est-à-dire
vous avez
bah c'est-à-dire que je suis euh je n'ai
pas une foi vibrante. Il y a toujours un
conflit entre les
mon enfance qui qui je suis d'une
famille juive traditionnelle et donc mes
parents étaient très croyants et ma
rationalité occidentale française qui
est plus agnostique et donc ce conflit
en moi est permanent et donc c'est pour
ça que je vous dis de sous forme de
boutade ça dépend des joueurs.
Je vous laisse continuer sur le le
djihadisme
et je vous en prie.
On reviendra sur le djihadisme. Je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur la politique
étrangère de la France. Euh je vous
donne un un cas un cas concret.
Je vous donne
un cas concret. Allez-y.
Euh quand la Chine
stoppe les exportations de fertilisant
de
fertilisant Hm hm.
Ça vous fait penser à quoi ? Ça fait
penser à à un crush énergétique ? Ça
fait penser à de la guerre économique,
ça fait penser à du protectionnisme ? a
fait penser à Winter is coming. Vous
connaissez l'expression ?
Non.
L'hiver arrive. Hm
hm.
Vous connaissez pas Game of Thrones ?
Non. Bon,
je connais de noms bien sûr, mais je
suis pas un un spécialiste de ça. Non,
ça se fait en un weekend.
Oui. Oui, mais j'ai pas spécialement
envie. J'ai d'autres livres à lire.
C'est important aussi pour connaître la
mém éthique et que prendre la
température de la population,
s'intéresser à ce qu'elle peut.
Vous savez, on peut pas tout voir, tout
regarder, tout. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec une Chine qui stoppe ses
exportations de fertilisant ?
Pour moi, pour répondre à votre
question,
c'est de la guerre économique et du
protectionnisme. C'est comme le fait que
la Chine ait euh euh interdit la la
vente de ses arbres. Je suis on m'a
appris ça, je suis très frappé par ça.
Alors que nous nous continuons à vendre
alors qui nous achète beaucoup de nos
chaînes et cetera. Eux, ils ont interdit
l'exportation de ces arbres, de ces
forêts et cetera. C'est du
protectionnisme. Les Chinois n'ont aucun
scrupule pour faire du protectionnisme.
Ils n'ont pas tort d'ailleurs. Euh c'est
comme ça qu'ils ont pu ériger des rivaux
à Google et à Facebook et cetera. C'est
en se barricadant et en interdisant
l'arrivée de ces mastodontes américains.
Alors que nous, au nom du libre échange,
nous avons nous sommes laissés colonisés
euh par les Américains. Voilà, les
Chinois, eux sont dans une logique
d'affrontement. Ils sont dans une
logique de je pense de revanche.
D'ailleurs, toute cette histoire
pourrait être résumée à des à des
revanches. C'est-à-dire que depuis la
Renaissance et plus encore le 18e siècle
et plus encore le 19e siècle, l'Europe a
dominé le monde parce que l'Europe était
plus créative, plus dynamique, plus avec
un respect des sciences,
plus fourbe aussi.
Les anglais, pas les autres.
Euh oui, les Anglais, mais vous savez,
on l'a subi nous aussi. Euh donc donc
l'Europe a dominé le monde et
aujourd'hui il y a un besoin, un envie
de revanche et de la part des de l'Asie,
en particulier des Chinois mais aussi
des autres et de la part du monde
musulman qui veut prendre sa revanche
sur une Europe qui a été hégémonique et
donc arrogante et donc humiliante et
voilà, c'est c'est le sens de
l'histoire, c'est sans fin. Je vous
disais tout à l'heure, c'est depuis 1000
ans flux et le reflux.
Il y a comme ça des moment de flux et de
reflux dans l'histoire du monde. Donc la
politique de la France doit se d'après
moi doit s'inscrire dans ce panorama
global. On ne peut plus faire comme si
nous étions dans les années 50, dans les
années 70 ou même dans les années 20.
Enfin, vous voyez, le panorama n'a plus
rien à voir. Il a complètement été
bouleversé par les selon moi, par les
éléments que je que je vous ai donné.
La France dans un phénomène de refus,
elle fait quoi ?
La population, elle fait quoi ?
L'industrie fait quoi ? L'économie fait
quoi ? Et les politiques font quoi ?
La France,
la France est très mal en point dans ce
panorama. D'abord parce que elle est
prise évidemment par le reflux global.
le reflux occidental
et le reflux des pays européens. Elle
est prise par le rapport de force
démographique. Vous savez, je donne
souvent ce ces chiffres parce que je le
je le crois très parlant. En 1900,
l'Europe c'est 400 millions. L'Afrique
c'est 100 millions. Aujourd'hui,
l'Europe c'est 400 500 millions.
L'Afrique en 2050 c'est 2 milliards.
Donc c'est-à-dire que le rapport de
force de 1 à 4 a complètement basculé.
En 1900, ça donne la colonisation
européenne sur l'Afrique. Aujourd'hui,
ça donne ce que j'appelle l'invasion
migratoire en Europe venue de l'Afrique,
Afrique du Nord et Afrique noire. Je
pense beaucoup, je pense que vous savez,
je pense que la démographie c'est le
destin, le vieille vieille phrase des
Américains qui en l'occurrence ont
raison. Donc soit soit la France. Et
pareil pour être toujours essayer d'être
complet pour mon deuxième ma deuxème
guerre de civilisation entre la Chine et
les États-Unis. Là si vous voulez nous
sommes à la fois
comment vous dire nous sommes à la fois
nous ne sommes pas en première ligne.
Celle qui est en première ligne sont ce
sont les États-Unis. C'est-à-dire que le
le le Napoléon et l'Angleterre de de de
1800, c'est la Chine et les États-Unis,
ce n'est plus la France.
Siè guerre par proxy, on est peut-être
le proxy des États-Unis.
Tout à fait. Tout à fait. On est C'est
ce que j'allais vous dire. Exactement.
C'est exactement ce que j'allais vous
dire. Et on est en deuxème ligne. Et les
Américains considèrent que nous sommes
des domestiques qui devons obéir. Je
pense que nous devons sortir de cet état
de suggestion. Je pense que nous avons
un double état de suggestion.
Mais ça c'est du wishful thinking.
Mais non mais non mais non mais non
c'est pas du wishful thinking.
Comment on fait pour sortir de l'emprise
américaine sur nos services de
renseignement sur nos tech ? Là là on
voit on voit que la
la CIA met un un pied dans la porte des
start-ups françaises.
On fait quoi ?
Mais je pense effectivement vous avez
tout à fait raison. Je je pense que nous
devons nous défendre. C'est une question
de volonté politique. Il faut
effectivement organiser l'État pour se
protéger. Je vous donne plusieurs
exemples. D'abord, je pense que on sort
du commandement militaire intégré de
l'OTAN.
Sarkozy qui nous a fait réintégrer.
Absolument. Je pense que ça été une
grave erreur de Nicolas Sarkozi. Euh et
d'ailleurs,
une erreur ou une forfaiture ?
J'aime pas.
Je je n'aime pas si vous voulez comme
ça. Voyez
Sarkozi, c'est votre copain ? Non, c'est
pas mon Non, c'est pas mon copain. Vous
savez, on est on a des on a eu des
relations complexes parce que j'étais un
journaliste euh d'agerre assez pugnas et
que lui euh euh c'est un type assez euh
comment vous dire qui humainement ne
supporte pas les critiques. C'est pour
le meilleur et pour le pire. Voyez, euh
Henry Geno a une très jolie formule sur
son ami Sarkozi. Il dit "Il est humain
trop humain." Voyez, il il ne supporte
pas la moindre attaque et cetera. et
moi, j'étais en tant que journaliste
assez pugnas et en plus euh j'avais euh
des opinions assez contraires au
siennes. C'estàd que je l'ai
considérablement critiqué sur cette
histoire euh de retour dans les
instances militaires intégrées de
l'OTAN. Je l'ai considérablement
critiqué quand Tila en 2007 aboli le
référendum, le nom du référendum de 2005
et qu'il est passé par la voie
parlementaire pour euh s'asseoir sur le
la volonté du peuple. Je l'ai
considérablement
compte critiquer, je le raconte dans le
livre en direct d'ailleurs parce que par
hasard j'avais un un vous savez un dîner
un déjeuner autour du du président comme
souvent les déjeunés de presse et cetera
et je l'ai critiqué sur ce cette
expédition en Libye qui est pour moi qui
a d'instinct j'ai dit c'est ça va être
une catastrophe donc vous voyez j'ai des
désaccords de fond mais je n'ai pas
d'hostilité personnelle et cetera donc
c'est pour ça que j'hésite à moi en tout
cas je pense que c'est une grave erreur
politique et que il n'aurait jamais dû
le faire.
Le fait qu'il se fasse accompagner par
de gendarmes pour aller témoigner sur
les les sondage de l'Élysée, c'est bien,
c'est pas bien, c'est normal, c'est pas
normal.
Je suis écoutez, je ne connais pas bien
cette affaire, donc je ne veux pas me
prononcer sur le fond de cette affaire
évidemment euh je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est passé vraiment dans cette
que la politique se fasse accompagner
par deux gendarmes pour témoigner.
Je pense qu'il y a un certain
acharnement des juges contre lui.
Manifestement, les juges veulent lui
régler son compte pour des raisons
diverses et variées. Mais
c'est votre interprétation ? C'est mon
interprétation bien sûr. Ah, vous me
demandez mon avis, je le donne. Donc
donc revenons à nos histoires qui sont
plus global je pense et plus
intéressante
coup accompagné de gendarmes.
Je je n'aime pas moi quand l'image d'un
ancien président de la République est et
est et voyez je moi je suis
je respecte les institutions. Je n'aime
je n'aime pas ça. Ça me gêne. Il a quand
même été président de la République.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ? Et le
goudron et les plumes ?
Non, justement je n'aime pas. Mais vous
pouvez dire ça dans un dans un pays où
on pratique le régicide ou quand l'élite
dépasse ses bornes, on leur coupe la tê.
Mais qui vous dit qu'on a bien fait de
guillotiner le roi Louis X ? Qui vous
dit ? Je ne suis pas sûr. Qui vous dit
que qui vous dit qu'on n'est pas
traumatisé depuis ?
Vous savez cette histoire de la
révolution, on pourrait c'est un autre
sujet, on pourrait en parler des heures.
Je ne suis pas sûr qu'on est bien fait.
Euh en tout cas, ce qui est sûr, c'est
que ensuite, on a entamé un processus
euh d'instabilité du pouvoir pendant euh
150 ans que le on a sans cesse ossillé
entre euh pardon cesse ossillé entre des
périodes de pouvoir autoritaires et des
pouvoirs euh parlementaires excessifs.
Enfin, voyez, on n jamais trouvé la
bonne mesure. Voilà. Bon, enfin bref,
c'est on va pas refaire cette histoire
et et le peuple français est à la fois,
attention, ne vous méprenez pas sur le
peuple français, il est à la fois régit,
vous avez raison, il guillotine les
rois, mais en même temps, il veut un
roi.
Attendez,
nous ne sommes pas des Suédois qui ont
un roi d'ailleurs. Nous voulons nous
voulons euh nous voulons un roi. Nous
voulons un roi élu.
Vous m'autorisez une parenthèse ?
Ah ben je vous en prie.
On a une question sur notre chat qui dit
"Bonjour Syerview. offrir une plateforme
à un ambassadeur des pires théories
d'extrême droite qui a déjà beaucoup de
visibilité, quelle est votre
justification ? Alors un mon pote, on n
pas justifié ici on est en France, on
reçoit qui on veut, quand on veut et le
temps qu'on veut. Parenthèse close.
Je vous remercie. Euh en plus cette
accusation d'extrême droite est
grottesque. Enfin bon, je je l'extrême
droite, c'est celle qui veut renverser
la République. Je ne veux pas renverser
la République. À part ça, il y a pas
d'extrême droite, vous savez.
Il y a 70 % des Français qui sont
d'accord avec moi sur d'énormement énorm
thèmes.
70 %
70 % sur des tas des tas de sondage.
Comment ça sort d'où ? Quel sondage ? Ah
bah de de nous je vais vite si vous
voulez mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il y a pas 70 % de gens qui sont
d'extrême droite. Et quand il y a 70 %
qui pensent que l'immigration n'est pas
une chance pour la France que on ne se
sent plus chez soi, que il faut
supprimer le droit du sof voyez sur des
tas de mesures comme ça que la France
est une terre de de
avec des racines chrétiennes. Enfin
voyez des tas de thèmes que je défends
et qui sont approuvés par 60 à 70 % des
Français que la France est en déclin, on
est à 75 %. Vous voyez, c'est ça que je
veux dire quand je dis 70 % mais c'est
pour vous dire que en vérité ma position
est plutôt centrale. C'est je je je
réponds simplement à l'accusation
d'extrême droite qui est ridicule et et
qui est qui relève du théâtre
antifasciste que la gauche nous sert
depuis des décennies. Mais parenthèse
encore une fois fermée, je comprends
qu'on reste longtemps en fait parce que
on multiplie les parenthèses et on
revient et on perd un peu son fil. Donc
revenons. Revenons à l'origine. Vous me
dites qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire contre
les États-Unis ?
Non. Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire avec la
Chine ? Ah bah non, vous me disiez
contre les États-Unis.
Non, contre la Chine.
Ah bon ? Départ, c'est contre la Chine.
Et après la deuxème question c'était
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les États-Unis
qui ont un
considèrent qui nous considèrent comme
des domestiques et qui ont un féodé qui
ont vous avez tout à fait raison qui et
vous auriez pu dire autre chose. Vous
auriez pu dire par exemple leur
scandaleuse façon de se servir du droit
pour accuser n'importe quelle entreprise
de corruption et pour pouvoir mettre en
accusation voir en prison les
responsables. Vous avez invité soir
monsieur Pucci
cette histoire que don j'ai monsieur
Pouchi dont j'ai lu le livre et donc que
je connais un peu maintenant est
absolument ignoble ignominieuse. Je
pense que les Européens et les Français
en particulier devraient faire des
prendre des mesures de rétorsion,
devraient faire la même chose aux
Américains. Vous me demandez qu'est-ce
qu'on fait par exemple là sur leurs
mesures juridiques qui leur permettent
dès que quelqu'un utilise le dollar ou
dès que quelqu'un utilise un ordinateur
parce qu'il y a des composants
américains de d'envoyer la justice de
façon extraterritoriale, c'est
absolument un abus de pouvoir
incroyable. C'est vraiment un abus de
pouvoir de puissance impériale.
Donc là, les États-Unis nous sortent du
dollar, nous sortent de Swift et on fait
quoi ?
On fait comme les Iraniens, on crée un
système bancaire. Je ne pense pas que il
nous je pense pas qu'il nous sorte du
dollar. Je ne pense pas. Je pense que
vous savez le général de Gaul, c'est a
affronter les États-Unis et ils nous ont
pas sorti de des institutions mondiales
et cetera. Mais je reviens à à votre
histoire de Chine. Euh je pense
qu'effectivement c'est là où est notre
problème, c'est que d'un côté nous
devons retrouver notre indépendance par
rapport aux États-Unis et j'y reviendrai
si ça vous intéresse. Et de par
ailleurs, il faut être méfiant avec la
Chine. Il faut pas il faut pas être naïf
avec la Chine. La Chine n'est plus le le
le grand la grande puissance misérable
reconnue par le général de Gaulle qui
était tellement contente d'être reconnu
par le général de Gaul en 1964. Ils ont
pas oublié, hein.
Ils ont pas oublié, c'est déjà ça. Donc,
on a au moins un crédit. Euh, j'ai de
toute façon, il n'oublie rien je pense
les Chinois. Je pense qu'ils sont sur le
temps long, ils sont sur le temps des
siècles que j'ai essayé de de tracer
avec vous. Euh donc, je pense qu'il tout
ce qui tout ce que je vous ai dit, je
pense qu'ils l'ont en tête et bien
d'autres choses encore. Euh eux, ils
sont dans évidemment dans leur histoire,
dans l'histoire de de des des
concessions du 19e siècle euh de de la
de l'impérialisme européen et cetera.
Donc, il ils sont dans cette revanche-là
et c'est ce qui explique beaucoup de
choses chez eux. Euh donc maintenant euh
par ailleurs, il nous croit décadent. Je
pense qu'il nous croit décadent. Il
pense non sans raison, il faudrait
nuancer évidemment, mais non sans raison
que notre individualisme euh qui a fait
euh notre force à partir de la
Renaissance, c'est-à-dire qu'on s'est
émancipé des tutelles religieuses,
obscurantistes et cetera pour aller vers
la science et cetera.
Je pense qu'aujourd'hui notre
individualisme est arrivé à bout à bout
de souffle et que il désintègre
aujourd'hui nos sociétés et que nous
avons besoin de retrouver le sens du
collectif, du patriotisme,
de l'autorité de l'État. Voyez, parce
que notre individualisme fou euh
nous empêche de d'avoir des des une
société ordonnée. Mais bon, donc
revenons à la Chine. Je pense qu'il faut
être méfiant. Je pense qu'il ne faut pas
être naïf avec les Chinois, mais nous
devons essayer d'être une position, une
puissance d'équilibre. C'est-à-dire que
nous n'avons pas à rentrer dans la
logique de guerre avec la Chine où veut
nous faire rentrer où veulent nous faire
rentrer les États-Unis. Mais en
revanche, nous devons être très méfiants
parce que vous avez parlé de euh des
Américains qui euh euh les services
secrets américains qui se permettent de
euh de de de qui sont qui se croient
chez eux chez chez nous. Les Chinois,
c'est un peu la même chose. L'espionnage
industriel de la Chine, c'est pas
négligeable. Donc nous devons cesser
d'être les naïfs de l'histoire. Nous
devons cesser euh de si vous voulez de
nous soumettre à la Commission
européenne qui ne jure que par le libre
échange et le le la concurrence pure et
parfaite. Nous devons retrouver des
compétences d'état. Nous devons aussi et
là c'est de l'autre côté pour les
États-Unis
cesser de chercher à tout prix l'accord
avec l'Allemagne parce que infin notre
problème avec l'Allemagne c'est que
l'Allemagne elle se soumet toujours aux
États-Unis finalement et que pour elle
son protecteur américain est
indiscutable et pas négociable et donc
pour pour c'est le grand problème
d'Emmanuel Macron pour ne pas lâcher la
main de l'Allemagne il finit par se
soumettre aux États-Unis alors queil
fait des diagnostics assez justes. Quand
il a parlé de mort cérébrale de l'OTAN,
il avait tout à fait raison. L'OTAN
n'aurait jamais dû survivre à la chute
du mur et la disparition de l'Union
soviétique. Et l'OTAN n'aurait pas dû
survivre non plus euh à l'incroyable
arrogance turque protégée par les
Américains. Vous parliez de proxy tout à
l'heure. Euh voilà un bon exemple de
proxy. Les Turcs sont le proxy des
Américains et qui ne nous défendent
absolument pas et qu'ils doivent et sûr
qu'ils ont acheté des S400 il y a pas
très longtemps.
Je sais bien, je sais bien, je sais
bien. avec mais avec accordez-moi avec
la avec comment vous dire
euh pour le moins euh
la tolérance des Américains. Les
Américains n'ont pas ils ont ils ont il
n'est pas é pas content mais enfin ils
en ont pas fait ils en auraient fait
beaucoup plus pour d'autres pays de
l'Alliance atlantique.
Vous savez pas ce qu'ils ont fait dans
le dos ?
Certes.
Revenons revenons à des cas concrets.
C'est pas des nuet de cohérence ce que
ce que vous racontez. Merci.
Et
j'essaye.
Ça ressemble un peu, il y a qu'à Faucon,
c'est vous faites un constat
mais en terme de de préconisation
opérationnelle de terrain, c'est
nébuleux.
Alors, je prends l'exemple de
l'immigration.
Ouais.
Ensuite, on prendra l'exemple des
Chinois, l'exemple des Américains,
l'exemple de la guerre économique.
Donc, l'immigration, on fait quoi ? On
fait un mur ? On fait pas de mur ? En
sachant le réchauffement climatique
arrivé, on renonce à l'hospitalité, à
l'entraide. On fait quoi ? On dit
maintenant les peau, vous crevez chez
vous, on a [__] la planète, c'est super
bien. Maintenant, vous allez on va on va
vous autoréguler avec le soleil. On fait
quoi ? On fait un
Vous avez une vision vous avez une
vision un peu comment dire schématique
pour ne pas dire caricaturale. On n pas
de résumer ma parole à schématique et
caricaturale.
Comment ? Merci de résumer ma parole à
schématique et caricatural.
Je pense je le pense là en l'occurrence
quand vous avez dit ça sur le je pense
pas par exemple que la colonisation
c'est ça c'est vous faites référence à
cela. Non
non non non, je fais référence à euh il
y a un réchauffement climatique, il y a
des populations qui vont être amenées à
bouger. On fait quoi ?
On leur tend la main, on leur tend pas
la main, on fait des murs, on fait quoi
?
Je pense que on ne tend pas la main à
des gens qui vont nous remplacer.
Est-ce qu'on tend la main à des gens qui
sont en train de crever ?
On ne tend pas la main. Les gens qui
sont en train de crever d'abord euh si
vous voulez nous qui allons crever si on
leur tend la main. Donc il faut choisir.
C'est chacun son cul et Dieu pour tous.
Absolument.
Nous devons sauver notre civilisation.
Voilà. Notre devoir pour l'humanité
c'est de sauver notre civilisation qui
fait partie de la diversité humaine. Et
si nous nous soumettons à votre loi
humanitariste,
pourquoi vous dites ma loi humanitaire ?
Je vous réponds.
Je pose la question.
Oui, enfin vous posez la question de
façon un peu orientée. Vous avez l'air
de dire que vous et vous amalgamez mes
réponses ou mes question pour me donner
une teinte. Je comprends votre question.
Non, mais je comprends le sens de votre
question. Vous avez le droit. Donc,
j'arrive à articuler des mots, c'est
bien.
Mais je comprends, je comprends mais je
ne je ne je ne vous fais aucun procès
d'intention. Vous avez le droit de
penser que notre devoir d'accueil
est supérieur à tout. Vous avez le
droit. Je pense le contraire. Je pense
que vous savez au au départ ils sont des
gens qui euh risquent de mourir. J'en je
répondrai à ça après d'ailleurs. Et
ensuite ils ils deviennent euh des
conquérrants ici. Donc si vous voulez,
moi je ne veux pas que mon pays soit
conquis.
OK. Donc si j'extrapole votre
raisonnement, on fait des des frappes
préventives et puis on on les atomise
tout de suite.
Vous voyez, vous êtes toujours dans la
caricature. Je n'ai jamais dit ça. Je
dis simplement je dis simplement que
nous devons nous devons nous avons, il y
a des chiffres simples, nous avons
275000 d'entrées légales par an.
Regroupement familial, immigration
familiale, étudiants, très peu de
travail 14 % de travail.
Vos chiffres, ils sortent d'où ? des
officiels l'INC.
Euh nous avons euh ensuite 130 140
170000 selon les années. C'est je parle
des dernières années 2019 de 2020 fausse
sympant ça fait la population d'une
ville française.
Exact. Celle c'est le droit d'asile ce
que j'ai dit. Et vous savez vous savez
comme moi je suppose que 80 % sont
déboutés mais que la plupart reste
puisqu'on ne renvoie que 10 % de ces 80
%. Donc on a à peu près, allez pour
aller vite, 400000 entrées légales tous
les ans. On a par ailleurs euh les
clandestins qui sont d'après les
chiffrage évidemment les clandestins, on
sait pas le compter au à l'unité près
euh qui sont entre 300000 et 900000
puisque euh on calcule par rapport à
ceux qui utilisent l'AME, vous savez
l'aide médicale d'État et ils sont
300000 ceux-là et on dit que c'est entre
deux et trois fois les clandestins ceux
qui utilisent la ME. Donc je vous dis
ça, moi je prends les chiffres
officiels, les chiffres des des gens qui
sont des spécialistes et que je lis. Euh
donc tout ça ça fait beaucoup de monde,
ça fait 400000 par an sans compter les
clandestins. Donc au bout d'un mandat de
5 ans, ça fait 5 x 4 22 millions.
Je pense que nous sommes mais nous
sommes en danger de mort. Cette
immigration est en train, je le répète,
de nous remplacer. Nous avons une autre
civilisation qui nous remplace. Donc
nous devons arrêter. Donc là vous me
dites qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ? Il
faut
interdire le regroupement familial, en
tout cas le rendre le supprimer
l'automaticité. C'est-à-dire que si vous
voulez, on a depuis 40 ans donner des
droits automatiques aux immigrés. Les
immigrés, qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? Ils
ils définissent la politique
d'immigration de la France. Ce n'est
plus admissible. Donc nous devons
supprimer l'automaticité de ces droits.
L'immigration familiale, le regroupement
familial. Quand on va chercher la plus
de la plupart des cas, c'est un un jeune
homme qui ou une jeune femme qui mais le
plus souvent c'est des jeunes hommes qui
euh sont originaires d'Algérie, de
Tunisie, de Maroc ou d'Afrique leurs
parents et qui vont chercher une femme
au bled bled dans le village de leurs
parents et qui la ramènent.
C'est 90000,
il y a 90000 avec le regroupement,
l'immigration familiale en tout. Il y a
25000 d'enfants et il y a le reste,
c'est ce que je vous décris. Il y a
90000 étudiants dont la moitié viennent
d'Afrique. Je veux dire, je pense qu'il
faut arrêter tout cela. Voilà, il faut
on renonce à à irradier des valeurs
françaises grâce à l'éducation.
Renonce. Ah oui, on renonce. Ah oui, on
renonce. On renonce à cela. Si vous
appelez les 900 étudiants par an irradi
les valeurs françaises, moi j'appelle ça
une invasion.
C'est un soft power aussi. Non non mais
je ne Non, je vais vous dire les b les
bons étudiants, les meilleurs étudiants,
ils vont aux États-Unis et en Angleterre
d'où qu'ils viennent
voir au Canada ou en Australie
parce qu'on leur fait des permis de
travail plus facile.
Non non parce que c'est plus cher et que
donc ils ont l'impression que les
universités sont meilleures. Nous on on
les fait payer le prix des étudiants
français alors que ils n'ont absol leurs
parents n'ont absolument pas contribué à
à l'édification de de de toute la de
toute la politique scolaire. C'est avec
nos impôts qu'on paye ça et pourtant il
ne payent pas un
la France a profité de l'Afrique pendant
des
Non la France n'a pas profité de
l'Afrique. La France a l'Afrique lui a
coûté la colonisation a coûté à la
France.
Le plutonium il sort d'où
le plus mon cher le plutonium on en a
depuis qu'on a plus des colonies.
Le développement industriel français
s'est fait comme le développement
industriel de toute l'Europe sur le
charbon. Il n'y avait pas de charbon en
Afrique. Il le le pétrole euh qui avait
il y avait pas d'ailleurs très peu en
Afrique, c'est la France qui l'a
découvert en Algérie. On a on a permis à
l'Algérie d'avoir une rente pétrolière
depuis 50 ans. Euh sinon, on en a jamais
profité. On il n'était plus colonisé.
Les les ressources naturelles qu'on
prend en Afrique, c'est depuis qu'ils
sont indépendants, on les achète. Donc
c'est pas la colonisation qui a permis à
la France de se développer
économiquement, c'est le charbon et le
travail de ses ouvriers. Bon, il faut
arrêter avec ça. La colonie nous a
coûté. D'ailleurs, je vais vous le je
vous je vous renvoie au livre Le pauvre
est mort. C'était un ami, monsieur
Marseille, qui a très bien analysé ça et
vous verrez que la colonisation nous a
coûté. D'ailleurs, quand le général de
Gaulle quand le général de Gaulle, vous
savez vous avez qu'à chercher dans cet
de Gaulle de Perfit, quand le général de
Gaulle donne l'indépendance à l'Algérie,
il le fait d'abord euh parce que il ne
veut pas euh comme il dit que son
village devienne colombé les deux
mosquées et qu'il pense que il ne peut
pas y avoir d'intégration des Arabes en
France parce que c'est deux
civilisations qui sont étrangères, ce
qu'il appelle l'huile et le vinaigre.
Euh donc, mais aussi parce qu'il
explique, vous verrez, vous le trouverez
aisément dans le texte de Perfit. Il
explique très bien que les colonies nous
coûtent très cher parce que les colonies
poussent la France en particulier encore
plus beaucoup plus que les Anglais qui
ont une conception euh commerçante de
leur colonie. Les Français eux veulent
euh amener les populations colonisées au
niveau de standard de vie des la
population française et d'ailleurs
veulent lui apporter la civilisation.
C'est le grand mot de Victor Hugo. Nous
sommes un pays dans la lumière. Nous
apportons la lumière à des peuples dans
l'obscurité. C'est ça l'esprit de la
colonisation française. C'est un
mouvement de gauche comment prétentieux
quand même.
C'est très prétentieux. Vous avez tout à
fait raison. Mais c'est la France du 19e
siècle. Et c'est un mouvement de gauche.
Ce sont les républicains qui colonisent
au nom de la civilisation. Et donc à
partir d'un certain moment, ça nous
coûte trop cher. Et c'est De Gaulle a
cette expression amusante. Il dit "Nous
ne pouvons pas leur donner l'égalité,
donc nous leur donnons la liberté et
alors bye bye." Vous verrez, c'est écrit
exactement comme ça.
Pendant la guerre 3945,
oui,
les Sénégalais sont venus défendre la
France.
Comment ? J'ai pas entendu, excuse.
Pendant la guerre 3945, les Sénégalais,
ils sont venus défendre la France.
Euh les Sénégalais se sont battus pour
la France, mais vous savez, c'est pas
les Sénégalais qui sont le plus mort
pour la France. Ils se sont battus
valeureusement comme en 14. D'ailleurs,
je suis étonné que vous ne parliez pas
de 14.
Laissez-moi y venir
parce que c'est surtout en 14. Mais si
vous parlez des guerres, si vous parlez
de la guerre 14, effectivement nous
avons fait venir des troupes coloniales
comme on disait à l'époque. Vous auriez
pu dire aussi d'ailleurs, il y a pas que
les Sénégalais,
il y a les Vietnamiens, oui, il y a
aussi les Maghrébains, les Tunisiens,
les Marocains, les Algériens.
D'ailleurs, il y a beaucoup de troupes
pied noires, on a oublié. Moi, je sais
parce que j'ai de la famille qui était
dans ces troupes-là. Euh je tiens à vous
dire quand même que ces troupes-là, oui,
il y a eu des morts en 17 comme pendant
la guerre 40, euh que ceux qui sont
morts en masse, ce ne sont pas eux, ce
sont les Bretons, ce sont les Corses
qu'on a envoyé en première ligne euh au
à la à l'offensive de 14 et et tous ces
polytechniciens, tous ces Normaliens,
Peggy morts, Sabr en 14. Euh c'est c'est
ce sont eux qui sont morts. Euh ce sont
les les euh les villages avec les
monuments morts avec parfois tous les
membres d'une famille sur le même
monument au mort. Euh la guerre 14 c'est
ça. Et 40, on oublie toujours 40 mais en
1 mois, en 2 mois, euh il y avait le
rythme de mort de la guerre 14. Il y a
eu 100000 morts et ce sont pas des
troupes coloniales. Il y en avait mais
il n'y avait pas c'était des troupes
françaises de souche. Donc il faut
arrêter avec ça. Euh elles Oui, il y a
eu des il y a eu des combattants, je ne
dis ce qu'on vient nullement. Il y a eu
des combattants valeureux. Par exemple,
je pense à Montecassino, les troupes,
les tabords marocains ont été absolument
euh d'un courage inoui, presque presque
hors de de proportion, mais absolument
admirable. D'ailleurs, admiré par les
soldats américains de l'époque, admirés
par les soldats et même terriblement
craints par les soldats allemands. Donc
vous voyez, je ne je ne je ne cache pas
du tout cela. Mais il faut arrêter de
croire qu'ils n'ont pas euh ils ne sont
pas sauvés la France. Ils ne sont pas
euh c'est pas eux qu'on a mis en premier
rang. Tout ça est faux. C'est des
légendes pour nous culpabiliser. Et je
vous répète, la colonisation nous a
coûté. Elle a ici et là enrichi
ponctuellement quelques grands
propriétaires. Quel encore une fois je
ne le n pas mais globalement pour le
pays. Vous savez, je vais vous donner le
dernier exemple et on passera à un autre
sujet.
À partir de la fin du 19e siècle, il y a
une un basculement économique d'ailleurs
qui va provoquer entre autres la guerre
14, c'est que les Allemands commencent à
devenir une énorme puissance
industrielle qu'ils en profitent
exactement comme les Chinois aujourd'hui
pour devenir une énorme puissance
militaire avec en plus des Chinois la
tradition militaire prussienne et qui
qui fait qui qui fait vraiment craindre
aux anglais qui fait vraiment craindre
que aux anglais que leur leur leadership
va être contesté et effectivement il
l'est. Mais l'Allemagne n'a pas de
colonie.
À l'époque, les pays qui n'ont pas de
colonie vont se développer beaucoup plus
vite économiquement que les pays qui en
ont. En vérité, les colonies ont été un
poids pour les pays qui ont été
colonisateurs. Vous savez pourquoi la
France a colonisé ? parce que après
la défaite de Napoléon,
elle était, si vous voulez,
en manque d'un rôle mondial et que elle
voulait garder son statut de grande
puissance et qu'elle avait été abaissée
par sa défaite à Waterlow, qu'elle
n'avait plus son empire magnifique, ça
c'est un empire magnifique, c'est-à-dire
l'Empire européen, c'est-à-dire l'Italie
du Nord, l'Allemagne Renan, la Belgique,
les Pays-Bas, ça c'était un empire qui
faisait la grandeur de la France. Donc
elle a trouvé un un un un pisal qui
était les colonies en Afrique. Mais très
très vite et à l'extrême droite pour
reprendre l'expression et à l'extrême
gauche, il y a des gens qui disent "Vous
êtes fous, ça va nous coûter trop cher."
Que ça soit Moras ou Clémenceau sont
contre la colonisation. Voyez, il y a il
y a des il y a des opposants à la
colonisation. Il y a ce mot fameux euh
vous savez euh en réponse à Jules Ferry
qui est le républicain euh favorable à
la colonisation et à qui on répond euh
vous euh nous offrez vous avez euh nous
avons deux euh deux sœurs qui sont
perdues, c'est les les euh l'Alsace et
la Lorine perdu devant l'Allemagne et
vous nous offrez 40 domestiques. C'était
c'était l'esprit de l'époque. Et voyez
donc faut pas croire la colonisation
c'est pas c'est pas ça qui a fait la
richesse de la France.
Merci pour ce petit cours d'histoire
avec votre prisme de lecture. Revenons.
Revenons à à maintenant. Allez-y. Mais
c'est maintenant puisque vous avez
compris que alors là je je je me permets
une phrase, vous avez compris que votre
lecture de la colonisation qui a permis
d'enrichir la France et le le le
fondement de toute la de toute
l'argumentaire décolonial pour exiger de
la France repentance et et rémunération
sonnante et tribuchante et privilège à
la population qui est issue de ces colon
de ces colonies. Alors, à titre
d'information, vous êtes à milieu de mes
de de ma de ma de ma perception sur la
situation de la colonie en France. Bon,
passon.
Bah écoute, alors vous jouer bien alors
c'est bien. Bravo.
Non, non, on on remet son micro.
Ah, pardon.
Ouais. La petite pastille derrière euh
la veste. Derrière la veste. Non, le
blanc derrière la veste.
Derrière la veste.
Voilà. Et par
C'est c'est aimanté. Amenté. Voilà. Et
là, on pose le micro dessus.
tout seul.
Vas-y, vas-y.
Ah non, j'
On va je vous envoie un technicien tout
de suite pour mettre le micro.
Excusez-moi, je suis pas très doué.
Donc pendant que les gens pu peuvent
encore m'écouter,
maintenant on a
le JC qui nous annonce des zones
inhabitables
en Asie, en Afrique, en Europe, aux
États-Unis, en Amérique du Sud, en
Amérique du Nord.
Ça va créer énormément de de mouvements
de population.
On fait quoi ?
Je vous répète, on ne les reçoit pas.
On fait comme les Australiens, on ferme
les On ferme tout.
Exactement. On fait comme les
Australiens, on fait comme les Japonais.
On ne prend plus de droits d'asile que
quelques cas individuels des combattants
de la liberté. On arrête le regroupement
familial, on arrête l'immigration, on
expulse tous les clandestins, on arrête
de les soigner gratuitement avec l'AME.
On arrête de les recevoir dans une dans
nos inertités pour trois fois rien. On
arrête tout ça et on on et en plus et en
plus on va plus loin, on expulse leur
délinquants étrangers et on on
enlève la nationalité française à tous
les binationaux qui sont des délinquants
et on les expulse aussi. C'est-à-dire
que on arrête Oui. on arrête tout. On
tend vers l'immigration zéro. OK. Si les
pays d'origine les refusent, on fait
quoi ? Si les pays les refusent, on
supprime l'aide au développement des
pays qui les refusent.
OK. Est-ce qu'on construit un mur ?
On ne construit pas un mur parce que il
y a des frontières énormes en France. On
fait simplement pour envisager une une
police militarisée des frontières qui
fait respecter les frontières.
Et on suspend Schengen jusqu'à nouvel
ordre tant que la frontière, les
frontières européennes ne sont pas
vraiment sécurisé, ce qui risque de
prendre du temps vu la mentalité
immigrationniste de la Commission de
Bruxelles qui relè avec le Parlement
européen
les attaques contre Frontex alors que
Frontex essaye vraiment de façon modeste
de renvoyer quelques migrants.
Oui. Euh revenons revenons aux
États-Unis. H
et on s'est rendu compte avec les
révélations de Snowdon que la France
était un gruillère pour eux.
Une mode de B.
Pas seulement la France d'abord
d'ailleurs.
Oui.
L'Allemagne enfin tous les pays
européens.
Donc on leur dit quoi ? On prend leur
diplomate. D'ailleurs, on a même pas
d'ambassadeur américain en France. On a
un chargé de mission. C'est le respect
qui nous porte. On fait quoi ? On prend
tout ce qu'il y a dans l'ambassade, on
les expulse et puis on vérifie ce qu'ils
ont au dernier étage de leur ambassade.
On fait quoi ? On moi je pense que vous
savez vous avez l'air faut pas exagérer.
Les Américains ne sont pas nos ennemis,
ce sont quand même nos alliés. Donc si
vous voulez, je pense que on est ferme
avec eux. C'est-à-dire qu'on est on
cesse la naïveté. Je pense que c'est
important la
pas entrer dans les détails là.
La fourmie quand elle est ferme avec mon
47, elle le comprend tout de suite
qu'elle va pas être ferme longtemps.
J'ai pas compris. Excusez-moi,
la fourmie qui veut être ferme avec moi,
elle va pas être ferme contre contre mon
47 longtemps.
Mais je je pense que vous exagérer le
rapport de force. Je pense qu'évidemment
les États-Unis sont plus puissants que
nous, ça ne se discute pas. Mais nous
avons d'abord nous sommes une puissance
nucléaire. Nous avons nous aussi nous
sommes aussi membres du conseil de
sécurité. Nous avons
un réseau diplomatique absolument
exceptionnel.
Vecteurs de nucléaire sont complètement
dépassés.
Vous croyez pas que vous exagérez un peu
là ? Vous
vous avez fait votre service militaire ?
Non mais je vois pas le rapport avec
l'arme nucléaire, pardonnez-moi.
C'est quoi un vecteur ?
Un comment
un vecteur ?
Mais en tout cas, écoutez, je crois pas
vraiment que nos vecteurs, comme vous
dites, c'est-à-dire les armes qui
portent les les les les armes nuclées,
la bombe nucléaire soit dépassé. Je
excusez-moi, je connais des gens euh qui
euh chez Dassou par exemple, pour les
rafales qui portent euh les armes
nucléaires, je ne pense pas qu'il soi
dépassé, au contraire. Je ne pense pas
que je ne pense pas que le les
sous-marins nucléaires euh que l'on
construit, vous savez qu'on est euh les
seuls avec les Américains à construire
euh chaque pièce de nos sous-marins
nucléaires. Euh non,
c'est plus vrai maintenant. Calstom.
Bon, OK, je je excusez-moi mais
turbine arabelle. Non, mais oui, bah les
turbines arabelles euh je connais
l'histoire évidemment puisque j'ai lu le
livre de Pierucci. Donc si vous voulez,
les turbines arabelles c'est absolument
un scandale. C'est pour ça que c'est un
scandale.
Ça s'appelle se faire mettre en la
Ah bah c'est euh c'est Emmanuel Macron.
Alors là, vous me parlez de forfaiture,
on n'est pas loin. D'ailleurs, vous avez
vu que il fait tout pour rattraper sa
bévue. Il essae maintenant à la veille
de la présidentielle de racheter les
fameux Arabeles. Donc qui est une
technologie, il faut expliquer aux gens,
j'imagine, je sais pas, ils sont pas
tous, mais une technologie qui justement
une technologie qui est à la base de
notre puissance nucléaire. Et euh et
donc c'est vous avez tout à fait raison.
Euh c'est absolument scandaleux de
l'avoir laissé partir chez les
Américains. Maintenant euh il faut aussi
se méfier euh euh de nos propres
réactions et des miennes aussi hein.
Souvenez-vous quand même que la filière
nucléaire française, la filière
nucléaire civile, mais vous savez bien
qu'il y a des liens entre la filière
nucléaire civile et militaire et
Bernardber
voilà était choisi finalement un modèle
américain, le fameux Westing House euh
alors que les Français
étaient favorables à une autre une autre
filière plus française. Donc finalement
c'est je crois que c'est Pompidou qui a
choisi avec le général de Gaulle
finalement la filière américaine. Donc
vous voyez c'est c'est plus complexe.
Mais maintenant vous avez raison. Les
Américains se comportent comme des des
prédateurs, comme des protect en fait
comme un protectorat. C'est le mot du
général de Gaulle. L'OTAN, c'est un
protectorat. Les États-Unis qu'on nous
considère comme des protecteurs et donc
le protecteur et ben fait fi de ses
protégés. Donc nous devons cesser d'être
protégés. Mais je vais pas vous dire là
telle mesure, telle mesure là vous me
diriez vraiment il y a qu'à faucon. Je
vous dis un état d'esprit, une
philosophie. Nous devons être fermes
vis-à-vis des États-Unis et nous devons
cesser euh cette solution. Est-ce qu'on
peut être ferme ? Est-ce qu'on peut être
ferme quand on peut
allez-y.
Est-ce qu'on peut être ferme quand on
est devenu une puissance de moyenne
impuissance ?
Oui, on peut être ferme. Souvenez-vous,
Chirak en 2003 a refusé la guerre en
Irak. Il a été ferme. Il a résisté. Il a
trouvé des alliés. L'Allemagne de
Schroder, la Russie du début de Poutine.
Nous pouvons qu les test nucléaires
français.
C'était quand les tests nucléaires
français ?
95.
Bah quand il a été élu en 95, euh il l'a
fait il l'a fait alors qu'il y avait des
pression justement de de l'Australie et
je suppose manipulé par les Américains
derrière. Voyez, il l'a fait. Donc il y
a il y a possibilité de résister. Je
suis désolé, on bien sûr qu'on est moins
fort que les Américains, je vais pas
vous dire, mais on peut avoir on peut
avoir des euh comment dire euh on peut
tendre la main aux Russes. Moi, je suis
tout à fait favorable à un rapprochement
avec les Russes. Je suis favorable à par
exemple à ce qu'on décide, puisqu'on
peut le faire euh solitairement en
Europe, euh la fin des sanctions contre
les Russes et qu'on arrête de les
embêter avec la Crimée qui était russe
depuis le 18e siècle. C'est comme si on
nous embêtait avec la Lorine ou la
Corse. C'est la même période. Donc vous
voyez, c'est je je pense qu'il y a des
moyens de de faire. La France peut
retrouver une politique étrangère
indépendante. En tout cas, elle le doit.
Et je dis pas que c'est facile, hein. Je
je ne dis pas que c'est facile. Je ne
dis pas que c'est aisé. Je ne dis pas
que évidemment la soumission est
beaucoup plus simple, mais ce n'est pas
digne de la France. Donc je pense qu' on
doit en tout cas mettre ce cap là.
Je reviens je reviens sur l'immigration.
Faisons une expérience de pensée. Le
réchauffement climatique s'emballe.
Il y a moins de récolte. Il y a moins il
y a moins de nourriture sur place. Il
fait trop chaud. Les gens tombent dans
les rues comme des mouches.
Ils viennent pour migrer tel des oiseaux
pour retrouver des températures plus
clémentes. On fait quoi ?
Je vous répète, d'abord je crois d'abord
je ne crois pas d'abord je ne crois pas
à votre je ne crois pas à votre euh
scénario catastrophe. Je n'y crois pas.
Vous avez lu le rapport du GC ?
Oui oui, je je lis je lis pas le des
centaines de pages. Je n'ai pas cette
prétention. Euh je je je lis, je
comprends, j'essaie de comprendre ce
qu'il dis.
Pas réchauffement climatique.
Si si, je je pense qu'il y a un
réchauffement climatique mais je pense
d'abord que les êtres humains s'adaptent
toujours à au climat, quelle que soit la
situation. Deuxièmement, je vous répète
répète que moi je veux protéger les
Français.
OK. Donc on fait une expérience.
Pour moi, pour moi l'immigration est
devenu le danger mortel mortel pour la
France et les Français.
Donc il faut arrêter. Donc quel que soit
vous savez Rome, vous savez pourquoi
comment comment Rome est tombé face au
barbar. Non mais est-ce que vous savez
pourquoi ? Non mais je vais vous dire
pourquoi. Parce que c'est la même chose.
Dites-moi.
Ils étaient les les les ce qu'on
appelait les barbares étaient poursuivis
par les un et
exactement. Et pour des raisons
humanitaires, les Romains ont ouvert le
fameux mur pour laisser rentrer les
barbares. Les barbares ont fini par
conquérir Rome.
Ouais, mais là c'est pas des barbares.
Vous savez, nous sommes tous des
barbares.
Anna Aren disait très joliment chaque
génération nouvelle est une génération
de barbares que nous devons civiliser.
Donc nous sommes tous des barbares et
moi j'ai l'habitude de dire
peut-être plus que les autres. Mais non,
c'est pas ça. J'ai l'habitude de dire
puisque je viens moi aussi du sud de la
Méditerranée, que je viens euh euh du
que je suis que je suis moi-même un
barbare romanisé et que simplement j'ai
fait le chemin euh des barbares
romanisés, j'ai mis la toe, j'ai fait à
Rome comme les Romains. Euh voilà, ce
parlez latin
non mais euh parler latin c'est dit
c'est rare. Euh j'ai fait un peu de
latin dans ma dans ma jeunesse, mais
c'est vieux maintenant. Bon alors bref,
donc tout ça pour vous dire que ils
peuvent émigrer ailleurs. Il vous
remarquerez vous remarquerez que cette
question on pose pas cette question au
Japon, on pose pas cette question à
l'Australie, on ne pose pas cette
question même à l'Arabie Saoudite.
Moi je vous pose cette question à vous,
mais moi je la pose, je vous dis non.
D'accord ?
Je vous dis quoi qu'il arrive, je vous
dis non.
Continue s'il continue,
mais s'il continue, ils se
débrouilleront.
Vous savez, vous savez que les murs
n'ont jamais arrêté des gens qui avaient
faim.
Mais c'est faux ça.
Ah bon ?
C'est faux. C'est faux. Je suis désolé
de vous dire les murs arrêtent les gens.
Le mur à la frontière mexicaine a réduit
l'immigration.
À quel prix ?
Mais je m'en fous.
Tout le prix ne sera jamais aussi élevé
que la mort du peuple français. Voilà.
Et pour moi, il en va de la vie et de la
mort du peuple français. Voilà. C'est
tout. C'est simple. Vous voyez, je suis
prêt à mettre le prix.
On fait quoi avec l'Europe ? On sort, on
fait un Brexit à la française ?
Non, vous savez, je pense que nous ne
sommes pas l'Angleterre.
Ah bah oui, parce qu'on n'est pas une
île. Bien vu.
Et vous avez raison, géographie d'abord
et deux histoires.
Nous n'avons pas gagné toutes les
guerres du 20e siècle
et donc nous n'avons pas la force. Nous
l'avions jadis au 19e siècle. Vous
savez, Standbal raconte que
on aviez nos colonies.
Non, pas du tout, pas du tout. Vous vous
mprenez, vous savez, sur les colonies.
Les colonies n'ont jamais les Français
s'en sont moqués jusqu'en 1932 à
l'exposition coloniale. D'ailleurs, ça
désolé les Républicains. Les il y a pas
de mouvement politique et populaire en
faveur de la colonisation. En revanche,
Standal racontait que en 1810, le
français se sentait vraiment supérieur
au reste de l'humanité. Ça peut rester
hein.
Oui, mais il y a aujourd'hui au
contraire un sentiment de de déclin de
de d'infériorité de culpabilité qui fait
que le français non ne il n'est plus du
tout le français de 1810 et je le
regrette moi mais bon c'est comme ça.
Donc les Français ne s'imaginent plus
seuls. Ils ont besoin de se sentir
soutenu avec des alliés, même si ces
alliés en l'occurrence ne sont pas très
amicaux et sont plutôt des rivaux
qu'autre chose. Mais passons. Donc je
pense que le Brex le le Frexit serait
une erreur, que d'abord on n'urait pas
de majorité pour cela et que en plus ça
désorganiserait l'économie. l'Angleterre
n'était pas dans l'euro, l'Angleterre
n'était pas dans Schengen. Voyez, on a
on a des liens beaucoup plus étroits et
donc les les les rompres euh
désorganiserait complètement l'économie.
Et moi, je veux me me focaliser sur ma
priorité qui est l'immigration dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure.
Vous êtes vacciné ? Oui, pardon, j'ai un
une dose. Euh j'ai j'ai eu le Covid et
j'ai j'ai ben j'ai une j'ai je me suis
fait vacciner avant les vacances pour
euh que Covid plus vaccin le meilleur
combo pour les les défenses
immunitaires. Je vous laisse continuer.
Je vous avoue que je ne suis pas du tout
un spécialiste. Donc on verra bien. Euh
donc je je vous disais euh là je vous
m'avez perdu euh fait exprès.
D'accord. Euh bon ben c'est réussi. Euh
donc savez
pourquoi je fais ça ?
Non.
Parce que quand je vous entends parler
en fait en préparant cette interview,
Hm hm.
J'ai mangé du Eric Zemour depuis à peu
près 15 jours, chose que je ne faisais
absolument jamais. Et
euh et j'entends en fait toute cette
petite tritournelle et c'est pour ça que
je me permets de faire une grande
interview avec vous
et de vous secouer, de vous perdre pour
voir qui est le vrai Éric Zemour.
Mais ce que vous ne comprenez pas, c'est
que le vrai Eric Zemour, c'est celui de
cette ritournel comme vous dites.
Voilà. et que vous neendrez pas même en
restant 10h autre chose.
Avec une bouteille de J Poulin, je vous
fais pr
même avec Ne vous inquiétez pas, je dis
exactement en privé ce que je dis en
public. Voilà, c'est simple. Moi, je
suis quelqu'un de simple, vous savez. Je
ne pas de sophistication de ce côté-là.
Euh donc, vous n'aurez pas un autre
discours parce que je crois vraiment ce
que je dis et je pense vraiment ce que
je dis.
Sur la question du réchauffement
climatique avec les les les réfugiés
climatiques, on vous les a déjà posé ces
questions,
ils iront ailleurs.
Voilà.
C'est la mort mais pas chez nous.
Exactement. Parce que pour éviter la
mort chez nous de notre peuple, moi je
choisis
la préférence nationale.
Exactement. Je choisis la préférence
nationale. Je choisis de sauver le
peuple français que j'aime.
Mais mais le peuple français avec ses
valeurs de de d'aider les plus pauvres,
ces valeurs catholiques
Oui. Oui. Vous avez tout à fait raison.
Vous avez tout à fait raison.
Comme comme Saint-Martin qui coupait son
sa cap pour donner au Vous avez tout à
fait raison. Euh c'est très juste ce que
vous dites. Sauf que euh vous savez, on
ne peut pas je crois que c'est je crois
euh euh je ne sais plus, je crois que
c'est je sais pas si c'est
Saint-Augustin ou un autre saint qui
disait "On ne peut pas vouloir le bien
jusqu'au mal."
Voilà. Donc là c'est on est en en plein
dans cette phrase.
Comment il a fini Saint-Augustin ?
Bah il a fini comme nous tous, nous
finirons malheureusement. Euh je je
d'ailleurs il faudrait vérifier parce
que c'est pas sûr que ce soit c'est
Augustin, mais en tout cas la phrase
j'en suis sûr. Et je pense effectivement
que nous sommes à ce niveau-là.
C'est-à-dire que oui, vous avez raison,
les valeurs chrétiennes d'hospitalité de
de maintendue vers l'autre, le pauvre en
particulier sont réel. Maintenant, il
faut quand même préciser
quand on dit les valeurs d'hospitalité,
quand le pape fait référence à ces
valeurs-là, on nous dit toujours vous
devez accueillir l'étranger. Vous savez,
c'est une phrase qui date même de
l'Ancien Testament parce que dans
la part du pauvre et tout le toit.
Absolument. et surtout accueillir
l'étranger. C'est ça ça vient de
l'Ancien Testament, même de Abraham et
cetera, parce que on dit au peuple juif,
vous avez été vous-même étranger en
Égypte et donc vous devez accueillir
l'étranger. Mais on oublie, on oublie un
petit détail, c'est que dans ce cadre là
biblique de l'accueil de l'étranger, on
vous dit en gros accueillez l'étranger
et ne et ne et ne le et ne le trucidez
pas. Bon, mais on oublie toujours de
dire qu'il repart.
Il reste un jour, 2 jours, 3 jours et
ensuite il s'en va. Il ne reste pas des
années. Il il ne il ne il ne il ne veut
pas changer l'âme du peuple français. Il
ne veut pas imposer sa loi, son dieu et
ses mœurs. Euh l'étranger quand il
devient français à Rome, il fait comme
les Romains. Si à Rome il ne fait pas
comme les Romains, il est un
colonisateur.
Le Gaulois.
Le gaulois a fait comme les Romains.
Nous sommes devenus la civilisation
goloomaine. Oui, galoromaine, pardon.
Voilà. Donc, si vous voulez, je n'ai
aucun
aucune culpabilité. Je pense
effectivement si nos valeurs chrétiennes
deviennent un danger, nous devons
d'abord penser à notre survie et à la
survie du peuple.
Non, il faut pas supprimer les valeurs
chrétiennes. Il faut au contraire euh
qu'ell d'abord qu'elle soit respectée.
J'aime bien parce que en général les
gens qui invoquent les valeurs
chrétiennes, c'est les gens qui se
moquent complètement du christianisme et
qui n'ont absolument pas foi en
Jésus-Christ. Donc si vous voulez,
n'oubliez pas que c'est d'abord ça les
valeurs chrétiennes, c'est d'abord la
foi en Jésus-Christ et ensuite il y a ce
discours d'amour et cetera. Mais l'amour
ne doit pas détruire la loi et ne doit
pas détruire la survie d'un peuple. Je
vous le répète, euh quelqu'un qui euh
par amour se sacrifierait et se tuerait,
c'est un suicide. Ce n'est pas un geste
d'amour et ce n'est pas conforme aux
valeurs chrétiennes. Il faut arrêter
avec ça. Là, nous sommes dans ce cas-là.
Donc nous devons considérer que euh
l'accueil de l'autre devient
euh meurtre de soi. Donc dans ce cas-là,
nous devons arrêter. Voilà, c'est tout.
Donc l'Europe
donc l'Europe doit également si vous
voulez euh l'Europe
nous avons une une à la Commission
européenne, au Parlement européen dans
les instances européennes une idéologie
immigrationniste.
En gros, c'est le raisonnement
économique, il va manquer. Les Européens
font moins d'enfants, donc il va manquer
des bras, des consommateurs. Donc, il
faut faire venir des gens. Et on se
moque complètement que ces gens aient
une culture des mœurs, une civilisation
radicalement différente et qu'en plus
euh ils ont pour beaucoup une attitude
agressive à l'égard de notre
civilisation par ressentiment. C'est la
discussion qu'on a eu au début. Donc je
pense que nous devons dire à la
Commission européenne, nous devons dire
au Parlement européen, nous devons dire
au juges européens, qu'il soit Cour de
justice ou Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme, que nous considérons qu'il en
va de la survie de la France et que donc
nous ferons qu'à notre tête et que s'ils
ne sont pas contents, c'est la même
chose. Si par exemple la Cour européenne
nous sanctionne
parce que nous n'avons pas respecté le
fameux article 8, vous savez de la Cour
de la Convention européenne des droits
de l'homme qui précise que tout homme a
le droit à une vie familiale normale,
principe au combien vénérable mais qui
nous oblige à accueillir
des centaines de milliers de personnes
par an. Ça, ce n'est pas possible. Donc
dans ce cas-là, nous dirons que nous
sortirons de cet article 8 et s'ils
insistent, nous sortirons même de la
Cour européenne droome. Vous savez
avant, sous le général de Gaulle, il n'y
avait pas de saisie de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme. Voilà.
Et je crois pas que nous étions un pays
qui ne respectait pas les droits de
l'homme. Donc il faut arrêter avec ça.
C'est la France qui a inventé les droits
de l'homme avec à la limite
l'Angleterre. On respecte pas les droits
de l'homme vu l'état de nos nos prisons.
Non,
écoutez euh je ne pense pas que l'état
de nos prisons l'état de nos prison est
dû à un au fait que simplement comme
nous avons effectivement accueilli des
millions d'étrangers et que il y a une
énorme surdélinquence de ces
populations, nous sommes submergés. Donc
je pense qu'on réglera les la question
des prisons quand on expulsera les
délinquants étrangers. Pourquoi selon
vous il y a il y a une surreprésentation
de la délinquence dans les minorités que
vous décrivez ? Pour plusieurs raisons,
on peut considérer que d'abord,
si vous voulez, il y a
traditionnellement
une surdélinquence dans les populations
immigrées récemment. On a eu ça avec les
Italiens à la fin du 19e siècle. On a eu
ça avec même les bandes pied noires dans
les années 50 60. Euh voilà, on peut ça
c'est la le premier fait qui est
indénégéniable et que je ne conteste
pas. Maintenant, on a dépassé cette ce
stade là et on a dépassé cette
époque-là. Euh je pense qu'il y a
aujourd'hui ce que j'appelle un djihad
du quotidien. C'est-à-dire que mais vous
allez dire que c'est Marie tournait
l'habitude. Je l'ai déjà dit
effectivement, mais vous savez comme je
vous l'ai dit, je ne diraiis pas autre
chose que ce
dans le 18e arrondissement de Paris.
Non. Comment
vous avez grandi dans le 18e
arrondissement de Paris ?
Euh à l'adolescence ? Oui.
Quelle rue ?
Doudauville.
Euh une rue qui descend du métro Châau
Rouge. Euh euh donc euh
rue le Thor, vous connaissez le Thor ?
Ah non, je connais pas. C'est où ?
C'est le c'est le cœur même du 18e.
C'est vers quelle rue ?
C'est juste en face de la porte de
client en cours.
Ah je connais très bien. Je connais pas
cette rue. Mais moi j'étais plutôt à
Château Rouge. Voyez un peu plus loin de
de Cours. J'allais pas souvent à
Cancour. J'étais plus pr de la chapelle.
Ah pas trop. Voyez versess
et la porte de la chapelle, il y a
château rouge et on descend la rue de
Dauville derrière la rue orden de la rue
Mira, la rue Léon. Voyez c'était
championn
la rue championnette. Non, c'est plus
perp d'opine en cours. La rue
championnat
par rapport à la piscine c'est où ?
Quelle piscine ?
La piscine où c'est championn sport qui
utilise
Ah mais c'est plus Non, moi je suis plus
côté barbesse, plus près de Barbess.
Donc euh je vous disais, je pense que ce
que j'appelle le di quotidien,
c'est-à-dire qu'on a vu qu'il y avait
une une interpénétration entre euh si
vous voulez le les milieux du
djihadisme, les grands attentats et
cetera, qui étaient tous euh des anciens
délinquants. Je pense qu'il y a, si vous
voulez une mentalité, une mentalité de
revanche que cette délinquence est le
produit d'un d'une volonté de revanche
sur les Français qui nous ont colonisé
et cetera, sur les infidèles et cetera
et que tous les moyens sont bons, trafic
de drogue, vol, viol et que nous devons
tenir compte de cet état de fête si vous
voulez pour prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent. Je vous disais par exemple,
je
fais l'avocat du diable. Vous pensez pas
que ces populations qui ont été parquées
dans des bidonvilles traité comme des
chiens avec les les les en c'était quoi
en 58 ? Il y avait pas des bidonvillees
à côté de Paris ?
Euh ils vivent où en Algérie ?
Pardonnez-moi. Pourquoi ils sont venus ?
Pourquoi ils sont venus en France ?
Pourquoi ils sont venus en France ? Oui.
Pour gagner plus. Donc on les a traité
comme des chiens en leur donnant plus
d'argent que chez eux. C'est ça que vous
appelez traiter comme des chiens. On
leur a donné du boulot. Ensuite, on a
fait venir leurs femmes, leurs enfants.
On a d'abord, on avait sauvé leurs
enfants parce que c'est la médecine
française qui sauvait leurs enfants. Je
vous rappelle que moi mes ancêtres
étaient en Algérie et on mourait du
choléra et du tifus comme pas hein. Ça
tombait comme des mouches. C'était ça
l'Algérie. C'était un cloac. C'était des
des marais incessants. Et la France a
saigni tout cela. La la médecine
française a permis à ces gens qui
étaient 2 millions d'habitants en 1830
d'être 100 millions en 1962 et 40
millions aujourd'hui. C'est ça les appel
cont chiens. On a on les a fait venir,
on leur a donné les allocations
familiales, on leur a permis de d'aller
à l'école, on leur a permis d'apprendre
la langue française, la magnifique
littérature française. On les a mis dans
des HLM alors qu'il vivaient dans des
gourbis. C'est ça que vous appelez
traiter comme des chiens.
On les a remis dans des gourbis. Non
non non non non pas du tout. Les HLM ont
été transformés dans des par des
gourbill par la population elle-même,
hein. Quand il y a une population euh
autre, les HLM sont impeccables et il
n'y a pas de dégradation et il n'y a pas
de vol. Bon, alors arrêtez avec ça. On
ne les a pas maltraité du tout.
D'ailleurs, je discute avec beaucoup de
Maghrébains, en particulier les Kabille,
qui le savent très bien. La France a été
bonne fille et bonne mère et très
généreuse et on ne les a pas parqué. On
les a mis dans des HLM où nous étions
nous les pieds noirs
simplement sont eux qui ont chassé les
autres.
Ils ont chassé les autres parce qu'ils
ont été d'abord ils ont imposé leur mode
de vie comme là-bas et en plus il y a eu
des bandes maghébines qui ont commencé à
faire la loi à à voler les les on disait
à l'époque les autoradio.
C'était le vol des autoradios. Ça a
commencé comme ça dans les années fin
des années 70. Donc moi, j'avais toute
ma famille dans les banlieux. Je sais
exactement ce qui s'est passé. Je l'ai
vu, hein. Donc ne me racontez pas
d'histoire. On on les a royalement
traité et on continue. Vous savez
aujourd'hui, vous savez aujourd'hui,
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure, il y a 14
% seulement d'immigration de travail.
Nous sommes passés d'une immigration de
travail à une immigration sans travail.
Vous savez, il y a aujourd'hui 8 % de
chômage en France. Il y a 14 % parmi la
population étrangère. Il y a aujourd'hui
13 % d'inactifs en France. Il y a parmi
la population extraeuropéenne 40 %
d'inactifs. Ces gens-là n'ont rien à
faire chez nous. Voilà. Et ne dites pas
qu'on les traite mal. On leur donne des
des un système d'assistana incroyable
qui nous coûte qui nous plombe notre la
compétitivité de nos entreprises.
S'ils ont des sils ont eu des enfants en
France, on fait quoi ?
On supprime le droit du sol.
On fait un charter avec tout le monde.
Absolument.
S'ils n'ont plus s'ils n'ont plus de
titre de séjour légal. Bien sûr.
D'accord. Et le pauvre gamin qui est qui
est né chez nous,
le pauvre gamin qui est né chez nous,
d'abord il y en a beaucoup qui détestent
la France. Vous avez remarqué, c'est
parmi la jeunesse. Donc il y a un
problème. Donc d'après moi, c'est qu'il
est malheureux. S'il déteste la France
et les Français, c'est qu'il est
malheureux. Donc il sera mieux chez lui.
Voilà, il est chez lui, c'est
non, c'est pas ici. La preuve, il le dit
lui-même. Il dit il est pas gaulois, il
n'est pas français. quand on lui
demande, il dit "Je suis algérien, je
suis marocain." Je comprends, je le
comprends. Vous savez, le roi du Maroc
nous l'avait dit. Vous vous avez vu
cette vidéo en dans les années 80 face à
Anne Saintclair. Il avait dit il ne les
miens les miens parce que il disait
comme Louis XIV, "Mes peuples euh les
miens ne seront jamais français. Vous
pourrez faire tous les efforts que vous
voudrez. La la civilisation est trop
différente." Mais ce n'est pas mal. Ce
n'est pas grave. Je comprends qu'on soit
attaché à sa culture, à ses mœurs, à son
dieu, à sa civilisation. C'est tout à
fait euh euh
mais vraiment euh respectable.
OK, changeons de sujet.
Je vous en prie. Moi, c'est vous qui me
je suis vos sujets.
L'écologie,
je fais juste un sujet comme ça où je
pose des questions plus
et Allez-y, je vous en prie.
On reste sur le nucléaire, on reste pas
sur le nucléaire. On continue auolien.
On fait comment avec la pêche ? Je suis
tout à fait pr à parler de de nucléaire
et d'éolien. Je suis
la voiture électrique pour ou contre
là par
voiture électrique.
La voiture électrique.
Ouais.
Vous savez votre permis de conduire ?
J'ai mon permis de conduire. Je conduis
mal mais j'ai mon permis de conduire.
Euh quoi comme voiture
? J'ai pas de voiture parce que j'ai en
fait je suis sous protection depuis
maintenant près de 2 ans. Donc je n'ai
voyez, je suis
Vous payz vos taxi.
Ah non, c'est la police qui me qui
m'emmène. Bon, je m'en seraiis passé
hein. Et moi je prends pas la voiture
dans Paris. Je prends je prenais le
métro. Combien vous gagnez ? Oh ça ça
vous regarde pas. Et là pour l'instant
je ne garde plus rien puisque je n'ai
plus
pas droit d'auteur rien du tout.
Ah non mais j'ai droit d'auteur mais je
ne suis plus né à C News ni au Figaro
euh ni à Paris Première à C News
mais ça ne vous regarde pas.
Euh je ne tiens pas du tout à vous dire
ce que je gagne. Je voilà voilà
l'écologie.
Voilà l'écologie. Euh donc on était euh
au la voiture électrique. Donc je ne
suis je n'ai rien contre la voiture
électrique. Euh je suis pas un fou de
voiture. Donc vous voyez, je je conduis
très peu. Je je vous dis dans Paris, je
conduisais jamais. C'est plutôt une
corvée pour moi. Je préfère prendre le
train. Euh maintenant je pense aux
100000 emplois que la France va perdre
dans les années qui viennent à cause
d'une transition écologique comme on dit
et d'un passage à la voiture électrique
ultra rapide. Euh je je ça me paraît un
peu fou surtout que la France était en
avance euh sur le moteur diesel, sur le
moteur thermique qui qui est qui était
euh beaucoup plus économe euh de de dans
en CO2 qu'on le disait. OK. On a fait
des progrès formidables. Maintenant, en
plus, si on veut passer à la voiture
électrique, qu'on bien nous fasse. Sauf
que si j'ai bien compris, nous sommes
dépendants des batteries électriques
chinoises alors que nous avions nos
propres moteurs thermiques. Donc ça nous
fait encore une dépendance. Je sais
qu'on parle de Airbus, de la batterie
électrique européenne et cetera, mais
pour l'instant on voit pas le le bout du
nez. Vous voyez, vous en riez vous-même.
Et donc, on va être indépendant des
Chinois, une dépendance de plus. Euh
donc on sacrifie notre industrie
automobile au nom de de d'impératif
écologique. Alors même que grâce au
nucléaires et à l'hydraulique, nous
avons déjà, vous me l'accordez, le le
nous sommes le pays le moins émetteur de
de CO2 d'Europe. Nous émettons, je
crois, trois fois de moins de CO2 que
l'Allemagne et 5 ou si fois de moins que
les États-Unis. Donc c'est pas la
France. Si la France aimait moins de
CO2, ça va pas changer la face du monde
parce que déjà elle en aimait très peu.
Euh donc je pense que comme la France
est plutôt vertueuse grâce au choix
nucléaires, euh je reconnais qu'on l'a
pas fait pour ça à l'époque. On l'a fait
pour l'indépendance énergétique euh
pour la bombe.
Et vous avez tout à fait raison. Il y a
tout vous avez tout à fait raison. Il y
a un lien entre la bombe atomique et le
choix de l'énergie nucléaire. Vous avez
tout à fait raison. Donc on l'a fait
pour ça, pour l'indépendance militaire
et de la du pays et de pour
l'indépendance énergétique quand il y a
eu le le choc pétrolier. Mais vous savez
tout ça. Donc nous devons là c'est une
technologie française, on était à la
pointe et nous avons des gouvernements
irresponsables qui depuis 10 ans ont
sacrifié cette magnifique technologie
française au gré des accords électoraux.
Je pense à Hollande. Vous savez que
c'est à cause de ça qu'on a fermé Fenim.
C'est pour un accord électoral à la noix
entre Martin Au qui était à l'époque
première secrétaire du PS et les verts.
Vous imaginez euh c'est pour quelques
circonscription au vert qu'on a fermé
Fessenheim euh une centrale nucléaire
euh qui marchait très bien et qui aurait
pu vivre encore 20 ans.
Les politiques qu'on mérite.
Ah mais ça vous avez raison. Ça sans
doute que vous avez raison. Mais enfin
on peut quand même critiquer ce qu'on
fait quand même et que Emmanuel Macron
aurait très bien pu. Il n'était
absolument pas redevable comme François
Hollande de ses magouilles politiciennes
avec le PS. Il aurait très bien pu dire
"Mais moi euh ce qu'a décidé François
Hollande, je m'en moque." Non, il ne l'a
pas fait pour des raisons encore de
communication politique pour faire se
faire bien voir des écolos. C'était son
époque écologique. Et maintenant, vous
avez vu, il revient au nucléaire. Euh
euh ce type dit tout et le contraire de
tout sur tous les sujets. Bon, mais ça,
on commence à avoir l'habitude. Donc
voilà. Euh si vous voulez le je pense
moi que
on a de la chance, on avait une énergie
nucléaire qui était qui assurait notre
indépendance et qui en plus et qui en
plus était économe en CO2. nous devons
la maintenir et la faire progresser. Euh
nous devons absolument
euh euh si vous voulez euh remettre de
réinvestir dans cette filière pour
attirer de nouveau les compétences parce
que le dédin avec laquelle euh nous
avons traité cette filière nucléaire a
fait fuir les meilleurs. Donc ils ne
viennent plus dans le nucléaire. Nous
devons arrêter en plus euh avec euh le
le pendant des énergies renouvelables
avec l'éolien. L'éolien c'est bien pour
les gens qui n'ont pas le nucléaire.
L'éolien c'est bien pour pour les gens
qui n'ont pas d'autres énergie. Mais euh
si vous voulez, on a vu ce qui se
passait en Allemagne au-delà de de de
laideur euh et de de l'enlaidissement
des paysages euh sans compter euh les
massacres de de petits oiseaux et
cetera, euh sans compter euh le béton
énorme que l'on coule pour ces
éoliennes. Le recyclage,
le Exactement, l'absence de recyclage.
Vous savez très bien aussi que c'est une
é c'est une énergie intermittente, qu'il
n'y a que 25 % de la capacité de
production et que donc quand il n'y a
pas de vent et ben on va chercher quoi ?
On va chercher le charbon, ce qu'on fait
les Allemands, ou alors le gaz. C'est ce
qui explique en grande partie la hausse
du prix du gaz aujourd'hui. Donc vous
voyez tout cela c'est une politique de
gribouille. On avait euh grâce à la
décision euh sage et vraiment
intelligente euh de de Gaulle, Pompidou
et Giscar qu'on oublie toujours qui a
qui a fini le le travail de de de ses
centrales nucléaires. Euh d'ailleurs, il
disait à la fin de sa vie que c'était ce
dont il était le plus fier dans sa
carrière politique. Je pense qu'il avait
raison. Euh donc vous voyez, on a on a
on a on a bazardé tout ça et on dit "Ah
bah non, c'est pas grave, on va la
baisser à 50 %." Pourquoi 50 % ? On nen
sait rien. Pourquoi pas 40 ? Pourquoi
pas 30 ? Pourquoi pas 60 ? C'est comme
ça. C'est c'est arbitraire en vérité.
Non, il faut absolument maintenir et
préserver notre
énergie nucléaire. Et d'ailleurs, je
vous dis, Emmanuel Macron a maintenant a
été une révélation, a subi une
révélation. Maintenant, il il ne jure
que par le nucléaire. Mais vous voyez la
la
l'impréparation et une certaine
amateurisme. Il nous dit vous ça vous a
pas échappé, il nous dit "On va faire
des petits des petites centrales hein,
les fameux
petits réacteurs pardon
pour faire des petites catastrophes."
Il y a pas eu de catastrophe en France,
arrêtez.
Il y a jamais eu de catastrophe. Ça ça a
tué moins que que le charbon et que le
gaz, le nucléaire. C'est pas parce qu'il
y a la bombe atomique que ça va que ça
va faire des catastrophes. Euh donc il
nous dit les fameux réacteurs, les
petits réacteurs, mais nous ne
maîtrisons pas cette technologie comme
nous n'avons comme nous avons négligé
euh le nucléaire depuis 10 ans, nous ne
la maîtrisons pas.
J'ouvre une parenthèse.
Je vous en prie.
Notre complexe nucléaire avec nos 50
vous avez jusqu'à quelle heure ?
Comment ? Ben écoutez, on conclut là. Ça
fait ça fait déjà 1h30, c'est bien.
Non, ça fait ça fait
1h23 minutes.
Et ben vous voyez.
Et eh
allez-y, allez-y, ne vous censurez pas.
Non, mais je me censure pasin. C'est
pour vous.
Exactement. Vous avez bien compris ce
que c'était. Mais bien sûr, mais moi
j'aime ce genre de vous avez vu je
complexe notre notre Oui. Nos complexes
nucléaires ne sont pas du tout protégés
contre la menace terroriste.
Est-ce que multiplier des petits
réacteurs un peu partout, c'est pas
aussi prendre des risques ?
C'est pas c'est pas une question que je
balaye du revers de main. Il y a des
risques évidemment, il y a des risques
terroristes.
Je pense que vous exagérez en revanche
quand vous dites qu'ils ne sont pas
protégés contre la menace terroriste.
Ils sont pas protégés. Quand on voit
Green Peace capable de faire péter un
drone avec des feux d'artifice à côté
d'une piscine de stockage, on rigole.
Moi, je vous prends un LRAC avec mes
deux copains, je vous fais péter une
centrale nucléaire en 10 minutes. Moi,
il y a pas eu d'attentat, ça me paraît
bizarre. Ou alors ils sont pas très
malins nos nos amis djihadistes.
Ah, vous avez peut-être remarqué des
choses. C'est bien.
Euh
question sur l'écologie. La France qui
est condamné pour euh sa diffusion de de
CO2,
ça vous fait quoi ? Ni chaud ni froid,
l'État c'est nous, c'est pas nous, c'est
notre faute, c'est pas notre faute.
C'est pas ça fait ni chaud ni froid,
c'est que euh je trouve ça absolument
scandaleux. Je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure, nous sommes le pays qui aimait
d'Europe et le pays développé qui
aimait, je crois, avec la Suède, si je
ne dis pas de bêtises, vous vérifierez.
euh qui émet le moins de CO2, en quoi on
doit être condamné euh pour notre
consommation de CO2, pour notre
production de CO2. Ce qui est vrai là où
vous avez raison, c'est que notre faible
émission de CO2 n'est pas seulement dû
au nucléaire, c'est aussi dû euh
à notre désindustrialisation,
c'est-à-dire que
est facile.
Mais non, mais c'est vrai,
c'est qu'on a exporté notre production.
Exactement. Et donc on a exporté notre
CO2 et donc notre consommation est
beaucoup plus importante en CO2 que
notre production. Là vous avez raison.
C'est-à-dire qu'on prend on peut prendre
le CO2 des autres. Vous avez 1000 fois
raison. Donc on peut produire notre CO2
chez les autres.
On peut produire notre CO2 chez les
autres.
C'est ce que je vous dis. Absolument.
C'est ce qu'on fait. Vous avez raison.
Vous voyez j'essaie d'être le plus
honnête possible avec vous.
On pourrait on pourrait on pourrait
aussi agir sur si vous voulez les
endroits où on utilise de l'énergie
thermique, de l'énergie fossile. On
pourrait les les logements, l'industrie,
voyez, on pourrait là faire un plan, là
je suis d'accord avec vous, par exemple
pour isoler les davantage les logements.
Il y a des choses à faire.
OK. Vous avez fait votre service
militaire ?
Non, j'étais j'avais des tas d'ennui, de
santé, un genou. J'ai
réformé P4.
Ah non, pas P4. Non non non, pas du
tout, pas du tout. Je suis pas fou. Euh
j'ai pas fait le fou non plus, même si à
l'époque c'était
c'était la mode. Mais vous savez moi
j'ai des j'ai j'ai pas mal de maladies
continent marchait pas mal aussi.
J'ai pas entendu. Excuse-moi. Éric
Zemour avec le feu nucléaire, vous en
pensez quoi
avec le feu nucléaire ?
Ouais. Ben si vous voulez, c'est
la la
le feu nucléaire nous permet de ne plus
subir d'invasion comme juin 40. C'est
pour ça que ça a été fait. Il faut bien
comprendre que quand le général de Gaul
fait ça, il est pré l'invasion de juin
40.
Quand Christophe Castaner vous met un
taquet par rapport à ce que vous avez
marqué dans un de vos bouquins par
rapport aux filles dans les bus et
passé du cocalan. C'est ce qui s'appelle
passer du cocalan. Mais quand quand on
donne quand on donne 1h23 euh 1h27 quand
on 1h30 h
euh si on avait eu plus
Mais allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, je vous
en prie, je vous en prie. Faire mieux.
Allez-y, je vous en prie.
Mais on va essayer de faire
Allez-y, allez-y. On peut on peut
gratter un quart d'heure. Ne vous Je
veux pas vous censurer, je veux pas vous
frustrer. Je sens que là vous
alors un, je suis pas frustré. Je suis
pas frustré.
Bon, c'est bien.
Et deux, ça nous arrange parce qu'il y a
une très bonne bouteille qui nous
attend.
Et alors, vous voyez, c'est parfait.
Alors, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y.
Castaner,
donc Castaner qui vous met un T.
Mais je vous ai répondu, non, c'est plus
sérieux pour le nucléaire. Euh je pense
que c'est, si vous voulez, c'est ce qui
euh fait notre statut de grande
puissance. Euh c'est ce qui permet euh
de parler haut et fort en France et en
dans le monde et surtout en Europe.
D'ailleurs euh c'est pour ça que euh nos
autres partenaires européens voient ça
de travers et en particulier les
Allemands. Euh je non non je pense
vraiment je pense vraiment je pense
vraiment que c'est un de nos atouts.
Vous savez euh le philosophe allemand
Slotterd a une formule que je trouve
assez assez jolie et assez fine. Il dit
l'élection du président de la République
au suffrage universel et la dissuasion
nucléaire, c'est le sacre de Napoléon et
la grande armée. Il est incontestable
que la dissuasion nucléaire, notre arme
nucléaire est un moyen si vous voulez de
d'imposer notre puissance en Europe.
C'est pour ça que nous sommes écoutés,
c'est pour ça que nous sommes entendus
et en Europe et au Conseil de sécurité
et dans le monde. Ne croyez pas que ça
soit méprisable ni négligeable. Est-ce
qu'il faut faire évaluer la psychologie
de notre président tous les ans ?
Bon non là vous êtes pas sérieux.
D'accord.
Revenons à au taquet de Castaner.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
C'est c'est assez bête. Euh
pourquoi c'est bête ?
Mais je vais vous dire pourquoi. Si vous
me permettez, parce que c'est dans le
suicide français. Je racontais, vous
savez, je dans le suicide français, je
je m'intéressais à tous les films, à
toutes les chansons, à tout le bain
culturel dans lequel on avait vécu et
qui ont changé qui a changé pardon notre
nos mentalités, notre façon de vivre et
cetera. C'était ça le thème de de de ce
livre qui remontait les 40 dernières
années. Et je euh je comment dire je je
j'évoque à un moment un film qui m'avait
beaucoup plu dans ma jeunesse et qui est
Elle court El court la banlieu 1973
qui est justement le début de la banlieu
et donc on voyait
voyez ça vous aurait plu vous devriez
voir ce film parce que c'est la banlieu
mais tel que je l'ai connu moi.
c'est-à-dire la banlieu avant le
regroupement familial. Et donc il y a
évidemment il y a des des des conflits,
il y a des il y a des incompréhensions,
il y a des agacements parce que le
réseau le réseau de transport en commun
n'est pas adapté à cette nouvelle
population qui vient autour de Paris.
Voyez, c'est on voit tout ça. Il y a
Mart Keller qui joue une jeune femme et
elle a une copine. Elles prennent le
train, le bus. Donc on voit la galère,
voyez, des des banliezards de l'époque
et il y a une scène où un le chauffeur
de bus ne peut pas s'empêcher de mettre
une main aux fesses à la copine de Marte
Keller. Et la copine de Marte Keller dit
"Oh, ça va, ça va." Mais je disais dans
le dans le livre, je dis "Il n'y a pas
d'agressivité, il n'y a pas parce que
nous sommes dans une société de
confiance." Et ce Castaner dit "Mais
c'est scandaleux, il monte sur ses
grands chevaux. J'ai deux filles et je
ne voudrais pas que mes deux filles se
fassent mettre une main aux fesses.
C'est dérisoire et grotesque. Je vais
vous dire pourquoi si vous me laissez 2
minutes puisqu'on a le temps. En vérité,
qu'est-ce que j'ai voulu dire dans ce
texte ? J'ai voulu montrer, je vous le
répète, la l'ambiance de la banlieu
d'avant le regroupement familial,
c'est-à-dire une ambiance pacifiée,
c'est-à-dire que c'est une époque où
même les gestes inconvenants, les gestes
qui ne doivent pas se faire comme cette
main aux fesses sont contrôlés par la
société. C'est-à-dire que celui qui s'en
rend coupable est immédiatement
surveillé et
et puni par le candiraton global. On lui
dit "Non, ça ne se fait pas et il ne le
fait plus."
C'est ça que j'ai voulu décrire. J'ai
voulu décrire cette société. Alors
évidemment, il va prendre une phrase et
il va mettre le focus là-dessus pour
m'attaquer. C'est pas c'est dérisoire.
Aujourd'hui, nous n'en sommes plus là.
Aujourd'hui, ces jeunes femmes dans
l'avantlieu ne pourraient même pas se
mettre en mini jupe comme elle se met
parce qu'elle se ferait insulter,
cracher dessus quand elle se ferait pas
tabasser par les jeunes de la cité qui
font régner l'ordre islamique. Donc ça
n'a rien à voir. On n'est plus dans la
même époque. Et aujourd'hui, c'est pas
Castaner qui défend ces jeunes femmes et
qui défend ses filles. Parce que ces
filles comme les jeunes femmes de la
génération de ces filles, elles sont en
permanence en danger à cause de
l'immigration justement et de les des
enfants de de beaucoup d'enfants de
l'immigration qui les agressent, qui les
insultent, qui leur interdisent de
porter des robes ou des jupes parce que
il les traitent de de [__] à cause de
ça. C'est ça l'ambiance dans les
banlieux. C'est ça aussi l'ambiance même
à Paris dans certains quartiers. Donc
lui, il a été ministre de l'intérieur.
Il n'a rien fait contre ça. Il n'a rien
fait pour protéger ses femmes. Et il
donne des leçons en disant "Mais je suis
scandalisé par ce comportement." Mais
c'est lui qui était indigne. C'est lui
qui voulait en tant que ministre de
l'intérieur mettre un genou à terre
devant une bande de mafieux euh qui
écumait la banlieu au moment de
l'affaire, vous vous souvenez, avec
l'affaire Traoré. C'est c'est lui
Castaner, hein. C'est Castaner ça, le
ministre de l'intérieur le plus médiocre
depuis 20 ans. Et c'est lui qui ose
donner des leçon. Euh mais j'en rigole
hein, j'en rigole encore.
Question internet. Par qui est-il
financé ? Qui vous conseille ?
Par qui êtes-vous financé ? Qui vous
conseille ? va pour l'instant juste
financé par personne.
Il y a effectivement
des gens qui souhaitent financer une
éventuelle campagne et donc qui donne de
l'argent aux amis d'Éric Zemour et en
prévision d'une éventuelle campagne
quand je serai si je le suis candidat.
Euh voilà, euh c'est des gens euh
divers, des vous savez, on a beaucoup de
petits dons, on a des des gens qui
donnent le maximum du plafond,
c'est-à-dire 7500 € et on a des gens
beaucoup qui donnent 20 €, 50 € euh 10
€. Voilà.
Question Internet. Est-ce qu'il peut
développer sur le parlementaire excessif
?
Ah non, je Oui, c'est très simple. Je
C'est un point d'histoire en vérité. Euh
ce que j'appelle le parlementaire
accessif, c'est euh ce que ce qu'on
appelait en terme de droit
constitutionnel le régime d'assemblée.
C'est-à-dire que nous avons connu sous
la 3e République en particulier euh des
assemblées toutpuissantes, des
parlements tout-puissants qui
bloquaient, qui renversaient les
gouvernements tous les 3 mois euh et qui
faisaient la loi et qui n'écoutaient
plus en vérité le peuple et qui
empêchaient les gouvernements de
gouverner. Voilà, c'est la 3e
République, c'est la 4e République.
Vous êtes plutôt Mara ou Robespierre ?
Mara est un est un terroriste
pour le coup. C'est un type qui faisait
des listes euh et qui les envoyait à la
guillotine. Robespierre euh
Robespierre est un si vous voulez c'est
l'ancêtre euh des Jacobas sont les
ancêtres des totalites. Et ils ont ils
ont ils ont mis en place un système
complètement fou de de de terrorisme
totalitaire pour imposer leur pouvoir à
tous les autres. Mais c'est a un mai,
Robespierre a été un patriote.
C'est-à-dire que quand il y avait toutes
les armées d'Europe qui envahissait la
France, le comité de salut publique a
permis de gagner la guerre et d'arrêter
les troupes, les troupes étrangères.
Donc vous voyez, il faut il faut
distinguer. Mais évidemment, son régime
est un régime
tyrannique, dictatorial, sanguinaire.
Euh je vous renvoie au livre magnifique
d'Anatole France euh Les dieux ont soif
qui décrit très bien l'ambiance à cette
époque.
Question internet. Quelle est la place
de l'environnement dans son discours
pour lui a l'on ouvert un effondrement
écologique
de biodiversité ? Et j'en profite pour
envoyer une autre question concernant
l'approvisionnement la sécurité
alimentaire de la France.
Un vrai sujet.
Je vous laisse commencer par ce que vous
voulez. Non, non, non, mais euh je ne si
vous voulez, je ne euh
crois pas à l'effondrement
euh de la planète, l'effondrement
climatique. Euh je en tout cas je ne
pense pas que la France soit responsable
de cela et je ne pense pas que le fait
que la France croire un effondrement et
que le fait que la France de
toute façon, croire en plus à
l'effondrement, je n'ai pas la
compétence pour savoir si ça va arriver
ou pas. Je n'ai pas la compétence
scientifique et je pense en l'
occurrence, moi vous savez euh je ne
j'ai l'habitude de dire ça aux
écologistes. Euh eux ils ont ils ont
beaucoup d'ambitions, ils veulent sauver
la planète. Moi, je veux sauver la
France. Et en l'occurrence, je pense que
le sujet majeur pour la France, c'est
l'immigration et l'identité de la
France. Donc et je pense que pour le
climat, la France n'a qu'un en vérité
qu'un rôle marginal dans cette histoire.
Donc il faut pas battre sa coulpe, il
faut que les Américains et les Chinois
commencent.
On vient de cramer 6 minutes. Il y a
votre conseillère qui nous tape à la
porte là. On continue encore combien de
temps ?
Et ben 5 minutes, on finit.
D'accord. Alors si on finit un livre euh
trois livres pour
notre communauté. Vous avez trois livres
à conseiller.
Ah que je peux vous conseiller moi ?
Ouais.
Alors là très vite les mémoires
d'outreetombe de Château Brillant.
Les mémoires d'outreetombes de Château
Brillant.
Euh illusion perdue de Balzac.
Euh alors si je peux euh un grand livre
mais historique qui est l'origine de la
France contemporaine de Then. Si vous
voulez un roman euh je dirais euh la
semaine sainte d'Aragon.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer.
défendez votre identité, défendez votre
culture. Le le peuple français a été un
très grand peuple. Il est un très grand
peuple avec une très grande histoire.
Notre notre rôle, notre responsabilité,
votre rôle, votre responsabilité,
puisque vous me demandez de parler aux
jeunes, c'est de perpétuer cette
histoire glorieuse et magnifique, cette
culture admirable.
La prochaine fois, s'il y a une
prochaine fois, il y a pas de limite de
temps chez nous. J'avais bien compris.
Ben là, vous avez mis des limites. B
c'est moi qui met la limite.
Ouai
pour savoir que vous savez, faut savoir
terminer, vous savez, vous connaissez le
mot de Thorise, il faut savoir terminer
une grève. Donc il faut savoir terminer
une émission.
D'accord. Allez
allez, bonne soirée. Merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]